Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und jetzt habe ich glatt die Freude, hier alle schon zur 50. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe zu begrüßen. Wir haben jetzt keine besondere Party vorbereitet, freuen uns aber trotzdem, hier schon so weit gekommen zu sein. Und ja, für die heutige Ausgabe hat mich der Weg, abermals nach München, genauer Oberpfaffenhofen, geführt zum Gelände des DLR. Und ich bin auch mal wieder an einen Ort zurückgekehrt, wo ich auch schon eine Sendung aufgenommen habe. Konkret beziehe ich mich jetzt auf die 14. Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Robotik in der Raumfahrt war der Titel. Und genau darum ging es eben auch. Eine Betrachtung der Anwendungsmöglichkeiten von Robotik, ganz speziell für die Raumfahrt. Das Ganze mit Klaus Landzettel. Und es ist nun so, dass halt im DLR das Thema Robotik noch sehr viel größer ist, als eben nur dieser kleine Ausschnitt der Raumfahrtanwendung, der, wie sich ja in der Sendung auch gezeigt hat, noch relativ klein ist. Und um mal das Feld ein bisschen weiter aufzuspannen und zu gucken, was da für Entwicklungen möglich sind und welche Anwendungen da in der Zukunft auch denkbar sind und hier auch ganz konkret untersucht werden, bin ich abermals hier an das Institut für Robotik und Mechatronik eben zurückgekehrt. Und begrüße Christoph, Christoph Borst. Hallo, willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist Abteilungsleiter für Autonomie und Fernprogrammierung. Das ist ja auch eine ganz tolle Visitenkarte, finde ich.
Ja, das ist zum Teil ein bisschen historisch bedingt, sozusagen. Wir haben vor drei Jahren das Institut eingeteilt in Abteilungen. Und das orientiert sich ein bisschen daran, wie man Roboter baut. Das heißt, wir haben gesagt, ein Roboter hat irgendwie einen Körper, der muss irgendwie materiell da sein. Er braucht Wahrnehmung und er braucht irgendwie Aktion und Bewegung. Und genau so sind die Abteilungen ausgerichtet. Wir haben eine für mechatronische Komponenten und Systeme, die bauen die Roboter. Wir haben eine für, die heißt Perzeption und Kognition. Da ist schon ein bisschen der Anklang an Intelligenz auch, die sich mit Sensorik, Wischen usw. beschäftigt. Die Autonomie und Fernprogrammierung beschäftigt sich mit der Bewegung, Bewegungsplanung, Ausführung und Steuerung von Robotern. Und das Fernprogrammierung kommt so ein bisschen aus der Historie des Instituts. Wir haben schon immer ferngesteuert Roboter. Die waren nicht so sehr autonom, sondern da ging es sehr viel um Fernsteuerung vom Boden aus, das Ziel dann irgendwann im Weltraum zu machen, oder telepräsente Steuerung, direkte Fernsteuerung von Robotern. Und das wollten wir nicht ganz wegwerfen sozusagen. Es sollte noch ein bisschen im Namen da sein.
Das heißt, Autonomie und Fernprogrammierung widerspricht sich eigentlich so ein bisschen, oder sind zwei Seiten derselben Medaille? Kann man das so sehen?
Es hat beides damit zu tun, dass der Roboter sich bewegen soll. Die Frage ist nur, wer ist sozusagen derjenige, der den Ausschlag gibt für die Bewegung. Einmal ist es der Roboter selbst, der seine Bewegung steuert, und das andere Mal ist er sozusagen der Sklave des Menschen. Deswegen sind viele Methoden oder was die Steuerung ursprünglich unten drunter angeht, relativ ähnlich. Das hat schon eine gewisse Verwandtschaft, aber ist auch natürlich sich ein bisschen widersprechend.
Wie war denn jetzt so dein eigener Weg hier zu diesem Institut beim DLR? Womit hast du angefangen? War denn Roboter schon immer so das Thema der Jugend irgendwie?
Eher nicht, würde ich sagen.
Gab nicht so ein Mondlande-Moment?
Nein, ich habe keine Roboter gebaut als Kind in meiner Freizeit. Ich habe Informatik studiert an der TU München und ich komme hier aus der Umgebung. Also Oberpfaffenhofen ist ein Gemeindeteil von Wessling. In Wessling bin ich aufgewachsen. Und ich habe, als das Studium zu Ende ging, mir eine Diplomabeit gesucht und ich wollte was zu verteilten Systemen machen, was auch irgendwie ein echtes System darstellt. Und da gab es ein Thema, das habe ich allerdings nicht bekommen. Hier konnte ich mich also sozusagen vorstellen. Und dann hat man mich herumgeführt im Institut und mir gezeigt, was es für Themen gibt. Und es war jemand da, der hat mir auf einem Blatt Papier aufskizziert, was es zum Thema Griffplanung, Greifen mit Roboterhänden zu machen gäbe. Und das war von Anfang an gleich so spannend und interessant. Dann habe ich gesagt, ja genau, das wäre es eigentlich. Aber ich hatte mir ausbedungen einen halben Tag Bedenkzeit, weil ich erstmal in die Unibibliothek gegangen bin und mir ein Buch über Robotik ausgeliehen habe. Ich habe mal kurz nachgelesen, ob das von der Mathematik her machbar ist. Und dann habe ich zugesagt. So ging es los. Also das war die Diplomarbeit. Und dann kommt man hier sehr schnell mit den Robotersystemen, die es hier gibt, in Berührung. Und das macht großen Spaß. Und deswegen ging es hier immer weiter.
Griffplanung, das war die Aufgabe?
Ja. Zu der Zeit gab es eine Roboterhand mit vier Fingern, mit deren Fingerspitzen man... Also mit insgesamt vier Fingern.
Einschließlich eines Daumens sozusagen.
Ja, genau. Also ein Daumen und drei zusätzliche Finger. Und man konnte damit Objekte greifen, wobei nur die Fingerspitzen, das waren also so als Kugel ausgebildet, konnte man da hinfassen. Und die Fragestellung, die man beantworten sollte, war, wie kann ich, wenn ich eine Objektgeometrie gegeben habe, Griffpunkte finden, die bestimmte Stabilitäts- und Robustheitskriterien erfüllen.
Also Objektgeometrien sind von...
Man weiß, wie es aussieht.
Was man anfassen will.
Genau. Man hat ein genaues CAD-Modell und dann ist die Frage, wo muss der Finger hin, sodass der Griff gut ist. Und das CAD-Modell hat natürlich dann schon relativ viele Dreiecke, wenn man es rekonstruiert oder so. Das heißt, analytisch ist da schwer was zu rechnen. Und wir hatten damals einen zufallsbasierten Ansatz gewählt, also sozusagen gewürfelt und gesagt, wir wählen aus und haben dann schnelle Methoden entwickelt, um die Qualität von diesen Griffen zu bestimmen.
Also um dann Echtzeit zu bewerten, ob das jetzt zielführend ist. Von welchem Jahr reden wir? Und das heißt, letztendlich ist der Ansatz dann mal ausprobieren, gucken, ob es irgendwie sich ziehen, drücken, bewegen, in die Richtung drücken lässt, wohin man es gerne haben möchte und wenn nicht, schnell wieder sein lassen.
Genau. Wobei man das alles im Computer macht. Also anfangs hatte man da gar keine Not sozusagen, die echte Hand zu benutzen.
Ja, also quasi komplett als Simulation.
Das geht sozusagen alles in der Simulation, ja genau. Und wenn man es dann genau betrachtet, hat man am Anfang auch die Hand gar nicht so berücksichtigt. Weil es ging dann irgendwann nur um Kontaktpunkte. Da hat sich auch das ganze Forschungsfeld drum gedreht. Also nur den Kontaktpunkt zu finden. Und wenn man die Hand dann dahin bewegen wollte, dann kann es auch noch sein, dass man eben mit den Fingern das gar nicht erreicht. Und dann muss man zusätzlich sozusagen die Randbedingungen, die die Hand liefert, in Form von Kinematik-Beschränkungen, also wo kann sich die überhaupt hinbewegen, was sind Gelenkwinkelgrenzen und der Geometrie. Die ist ja nicht infinitesimal klein, die Hand, sondern die hat Ausmaße und da kann ich keine Durchdringung mit dem Objekt haben. Das muss man dann auch noch berücksichtigen. Und das kann man als Optimierungsproblem sehen oder man kann sieben. Wir haben sozusagen eine große Zahl von Griffen generiert und dann ausgesiebt und versucht einfache Methoden ohne große Kollisionschecks zu bewerkstelligen zu müssen, sodass man schnell ist. So dass ich sage, in drei Sekunden habe ich 100 Griffe generiert und dann habe ich so ein Rating und dann bin ich in der Nähe von einem menschlichen Griff. Das war auch das erste Mal, dass wir uns dann...
In der Nähe im Sinne von genauso schnell, genauso fest, genauso optimal.
Wie soll man das ausdrücken? Man kann ausrechnen, wie viel Störkraft kann ich auf ein Objekt aufbringen, sodass es irgendwann aus der Hand gleitet. Ich kann mir vorstellen, ich habe ein Objekt gegriffen, da zieht jetzt einer dran in einer bestimmten Richtung und der Gegenspieler zieht in der dümmsten Richtung für mich und versucht es mir aus der Hand zu ziehen.
Also wie fest hält man es fest?
Genau, wie fest kann ich es überhaupt in dieser Position festhalten, theoretisch. Mein Ingenieur sagt dann immer, wir versuchen ein Optimierungsverfahren laufen zu lassen, das Maximum rauszuholen für ein bestimmtes Objekt. Da stellt man dann fest, dass man mit den meisten Händen dieses Optimum gar nicht erreichen kann. Das ist was, was theoretisch eine Fixierung des Objekts gibt, aber mit einer echten Hand kann man es kaum greifen. Dann haben wir uns angeschaut, wie typische menschliche Griffe sind. Da kann man sich angucken, wie greift ein Menschenobjekt. Ich lasse Leute das ausprobieren, oder ich nehme eine Griffdatenbank oder eine Ergonomie-Datenbank und schaue mir die Griffe an, die da am häufigsten vorkommen. Für die rechne ich jetzt auch mit meiner Bewertungsmethode die Qualität aus. Da stellt man fest, wir sind eigentlich ganz schön weit weg vom Optimum. Wir greifen eigentlich nur durchschnittlich zu. Ach, aber schon in so einem Bereich?
Good enough?
Ja, gut enough auf jeden Fall, weil da kann man sich eine Verteilung anschauen, von was es an Griffen an Objekten gibt. Und da sind wir eben ein ganzes Stück weg vom Optimum. Aber es reicht offensichtlich, um unsere Aufgaben da zu lösen.
Das bezieht sich jetzt auf so, also was ist das für ein, ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, man hat so einen Raum, dann liegen da vier, fünf Objekte und man lässt irgendwelche Leute reinkommen, sagt hier nimm mal, halt mal, greif mal und dann guckt man einfach, was die auswählen sozusagen intuitiv.
Genau, das mussten wir nicht selber machen, das gibt es schon.
Okay, geht es jetzt nur um den First-Context, so die erste Idee oder schon auch irgendwie, jetzt hast du es 30 mal gemacht, versuchst mal anders zu halten, dass so dieser Lerneffekt da auch noch mit drin ist? Oder ändert sich das dann nicht mehr?
Also was uns interessiert hat, sind Grundgeometrien und wenn es erwachsene Leute sind, dann haben die, da ändert sich nicht mehr viel.
Die haben einfach ihre Methode, die Pyramide zu packen.
Genau. Also da ging es dann eher um Details. Wenn man Werkzeuge greift, macht man das richtig oder falsch. Das haben wir nicht weiter untersucht, weil da wird es dann auch sehr detailliert. Da geht es sehr in die Art, wie die Hand gestaltet ist. Unsere Roboterhand ist natürlich doch schon deutlich verschieden.
Ich meine, es gibt ja durchaus Momente, da ist das ja auch wichtig, wenn man jetzt sagt, nimm so einen Schraubendreher und wir fassen den gar nicht optimal an. Kann man ja vom Roboter noch lernen.
Genau, was ich jetzt beschrieben habe, ist, wenn ich das Objekt einfach aufnehmen will. Das einfachste, am Ende kommt eine sogenannte Pick-and-Place-Operation raus. Ich will das Objekt nehmen und irgendwo anders hinlegen. Das ist das Einfachste, was man machen kann. Wie muss ich es jetzt nehmen, sodass es mir nicht rausfällt? Und wenn unterwegs eine Störung ist, dass ich wieder hinlegen kann. Das ist die Grundfrage. Die berücksichtigt eben noch nicht, dass ich die meisten Dinge, die ich greife, die will ich nicht einfach von A nach B schieben, also Steine von links nach rechts tun. Das mache ich vielleicht im Weltraum, aber am Boden eher nicht. Sondern die haben einen Sinn, eine Funktion. Also die haben ein Werkzeugteil, kann man sagen, die Objekte. Und sie haben einen Teil, wo ich es greife. Und jetzt ist beim Schraubendreher so, dass ich so greifen muss, dass ich ein bestimmtes Moment aufbringen kann oder einen Hammer. Den greife ich hinten am Schaft, damit ich vorne mit dem Hebel ordentlich zuhauen kann. Das war da noch nicht berücksichtigt. Das muss ich natürlich auch. Dann kann man sagen, Aufgaben orientiertes Greifen. Wir haben dann da so ein englisches Task Workspace eingerichtet und gesagt, was wir eigentlich suchen ist der Vergleich zwischen dem, was kann ein Griff leisten und dem, was er soll. Und das, was er soll, ergibt sich aus der Aufgabe. Das heißt, ich mache aber eine Aufgabenbeschreibung und ich rechne jetzt sozusagen die Störkräfte, die durch die Aufgabe kommen, zurück und vergleiche es dann. Und wenn der Griff mehr kann als was ich muss, also was meine Aufgabe ist, dann ist gut. Und wenn er weniger kann, dann ist ein Problem.
Also so ein bisschen so um einen Ball von A nach B zu bringen, kann ich den eigentlich irgendwie halten. Aber wenn ich das Ganze im Basketball-Court mache und 20 Leute laufen mich um mich herum und versuchen mir diesen Ball aus der Hand zu schlagen, dann muss ich schon deutlich effizienter zugreifen, um eben dann diesen höheren Anforderungen auch gerecht zu werden.
Oder wenn man ein anderes Beispiel nicht gerade Sport ist, ich will ein Streichholz anzünden, dann darf ich es nicht am Kopf halten, wo ich es anzünden will. Und wenn ich es irgendwie quer halte, so dass ich es nicht ordentlich drüber streichen kann, geht es auch nicht.
Okay, Anforderungsmanagement. Jetzt wundere ich mich so ein bisschen, dass sowas 1998 noch so im Forschungsmittelpunkt stellt. Man möchte ja fast glauben, dass solche Sachen schon früher angegangen wurden. Aber so eigentlich ist da noch viel zu forschen.
Es gab schon relativ viel Theorie, wie man das rechnen kann und was vom Roboter ausgeht, aber was lang dauert. Also wenn ich ein Optimierungsverfahren habe und es rechnet dann nach 20 Minuten, kommt das Optimum raus, dann ist es aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht in Ordnung. Nur am echten System hilft es mir nicht viel. Und jetzt kommt die Besonderheit, die wir haben hier am Institut. Wir haben die Roboter, das heißt, wir hatten wirklich eine Hand da und wir hatten auch einen Arm dran. Und dann stellt man sich natürlich vor, warum macht man das, warum soll der Roboter das selber machen. Ich möchte eigentlich so ein kleines Helferlein haben, der soll gewisse Sachen machen können auf Zuruf sozusagen. Ich gebe ihm Kommandos und sage, gib mir mal diese Flasche da oder gib mir irgendwas vom Tisch und dann schaut er sich das an und dann rechnet er seinen Griff aus und dann führt er ihn aus. Und da will ich natürlich nicht länger als, sagen wir mal, zehn Sekunden warten. Zehn Sekunden ist schon ziemlich lang. Und dann muss ich ein Verfahren entwickeln, das innerhalb dieser zehn Sekunden die ganze Aufgabe löst. Sonst macht das keinen Sinn. Also wenn ich ein Roboter-System habe und das soll mir assistieren und ich muss ständig auf das Ding warten, bringt das eigentlich für den praktischen Nutzen null. Und deswegen muss man dann schauen und sagen, was suche ich denn wirklich? Deswegen kamen wir auch drauf, um zu sagen, wir interessieren uns eigentlich nicht für den optimalen Griff, sondern wir suchen einen, der dem Leistungsvermögen des Menschen entspricht, weil wir dann davon ausgehen, dass das funktioniert, dass das gut genug ist. Weil was ist gut genug? Ist schwierig, weil da kommt irgendeine Zahl raus. Da kommt eine Bewertungseinheit aus 3,5 oder 4,6. Was bedeutet das? Was ist die Bedeutung in der realen Welt? Und ein Maßstab ist halt an der Stelle, wenn man sich mit Händen, Armen und Humanoiden Robotern beschäftigt, immer der Mensch. Da hat man ein gutes Vergleichsmaß, das ist relativ intuitiv. Wenn man die Leistungsfähigkeit beurteilt, woher das kommt, ist eine schwierigere Frage.
Das heißt, nach dieser initialen Herausforderung, von der ich mal ausgehe, dass du sie auf vielen Ebenen gemeistert hast, sonst wärst du wahrscheinlich nicht hier geblieben, schloss ich dann die weitere Forschung mehr oder weniger direkt an. Was ist denn hier eigentlich die Gesamtausrichtung des Instituts? Ich hatte ja schon gesagt, für den Raumfahrt-Teil wird hier definitiv auch zugearbeitet, aber das ist ja quasi nur ein Feld. Die ganzen anderen Aktivitäten sind ja sehr viel breiter aufgestellt. Was ist so der Wirkungskreis des Instituts? Wohin forscht man und entwickelt man?
Also ich würde jetzt sagen, der Raumfahrtbereich ist sicher nicht alles, aber das ist sozusagen die eine Triebfeder. Deswegen sind wir auch im DLR. Wir wollen Roboter-Systeme oder mechatronische Systeme entwickeln. Wir machen dann auch die Antriebe und die Motoren und all diese Dinge selber teilweise, die wir einsetzen können, um im Weltraum Reparaturarbeiten machen zu können, im Orbit-Umgebungen zum Beispiel. Wir wollen Roboter haben, die irgendwann assistieren können, wenn ich mit einem Astronauten auf dem Mond oder Mars oder sonst wo hingehen kann oder auch zusammen mit Robotern so etwas wie eine ISS aufzubauen. Und in der weiteren Weltraumumgebung, also wenn ich Richtung Mars denke oder auf irgendwelche anderen Himmelskörper, dass man autonom Exploration machen kann. Das ist so eine Triebfeder. Und Systeme, die diese Anforderungen aushalten und die man da einsetzen kann, entwickeln wir hier. Immer ein ganzes System. Und dann stellt man halt fest, dass man für Anwendungen auf der Erde auch ähnliche Anforderungen hat. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf die Leichtbau-Roboter-Entwicklung oder die Hände gehe, sagt man, die Zielrichtung war ursprünglich, einen verlängerten Arm des Menschen im Weltraum zu haben. Ein Arm und eine Hand. Und dann kann ich vom Boden aus agieren. Dazu muss der Arm leicht sein. Er darf nicht viel Strom verbrauchen. Ich habe nicht so viel Energie im Weltraum zur Verfügung. Die muss ich alle irgendwie über Solarzellen erzeugen. Und Gewicht ist ein Problem, weil ich muss es fliegen. Ich muss es da oben antreiben können und so weiter. Und die Anforderungen habe ich, wenn ich jetzt mobile Service-Roboter auf der Erde sehe. Die sind auch am Akku, weil sonst muss ich ja ein Stromkabel immer herumziehen. Habe ich also die Energieanforderungen auch. Von der Größe her habe ich es ähnlich. Und wenn ich an die Zusammenarbeit der Roboter, Astronaut oder Roboter Mensch am Boden habe, habe ich ähnliche Anforderungen. Das heißt, ich kann viele Dinge fast eins zu eins am Boden einsetzen. Ich habe den Vorteil, dass ich mit billigeren Bauteilen arbeiten kann. Also ich muss nicht alles Raumfahrt qualifiziert haben. Aber natürlich habe ich ähnliche Anforderungen, was die Sicherheit anbetrifft. Ich meine, im Weltraum muss man gucken, dass es funktioniert und dass es im Fehlerfall Prozeduren gibt, was passiert. Und am Boden ist es so, wenn ich in Interaktion mit dem Menschen treten will, dann muss es auch sicher sein. Da habe ich eigentlich die gleich hohen Anforderungen. Das heißt, da gibt es viele Parallelen. Deswegen versuchen wir alles, was wir in Richtung Weltraum denken, auch zu überlegen, wie kann man es am Boden einsetzen. Da hat man vor allem vom Institut jetzt gehört, die Leichtbau-Roboter-Technologie. Wir haben einen Roboter-Arm entwickelt mit 7 Freiheitsgraden, der besonders leicht ist, der sehr viel an Elektronik und an Regelungstechnik schon integriert hat, sodass man daraus auch schön Service-Roboter bauen kann. Und der ist so weit getrieben worden, dass man ihn jetzt kommerziell kaufen kann. Es gibt eine Firma, mit der wir Kooperation haben, und die hat ihn lizenziert und über die bekommt man das jetzt. Das heißt, wir versuchen schon auch eine Relevanz oder einen Impact für Anwendungen auf der Erde zu haben. Und das auch zu zeigen. Das heißt, es gibt dann auch viele Demonstratoren, wo man sagt, was hat das jetzt mit Weltraum zu tun? Wenn ich sage, ich habe eine Fertigungszelle nachgestellt und zeige, was man mit unseren nachgiebigen Robotern da machen kann, da hilft es meistens nichts, wenn ich jetzt irgendeine Weltraumanwendung, irgendwelche MLI Folien da irgendwo wegziehe. Da hat man am Boden, wenn man mit Weltraum nichts zu tun hat, keinen Bezug, was das jetzt bedeuten kann für eine industrielle Fertigung zum Beispiel.
Bleiben wir trotzdem noch mal kurz im Weltraum. Du hast ja gesagt, ja hier so reparieren im Weltall ist ja eine prima Anwendung für Roboter. Das kommt so sehr ja derzeit noch gar nicht zum Einsatz. Also Reparaturen werden dann doch primär von Astronauten gemacht. Die helfen sich zwar mit Roboter-Armen, also dieser Canadarm zum Beispiel, eine ISS, dieser riesen Apparat, der ist ja da sehr sichtbar auch immer, wenn man auf ein Modell schaut. Der wird natürlich dort eingesetzt, aber das ist eben jetzt nicht sonderlich autonom automatisch. Da hast du ja noch gesagt, Exploration hier, Rover auf anderen Planeten. Ich meine, da wird ja schon ganz gut rumgefahren und ein Stück weit Autonomie haben diese Roboter ja auch schon, weil sie ja gar nicht in Echtzeit gesteuert werden können, oder?
Bei der Exploration hat man die natürliche Beschränkung, dass man sagt, wenn ich am Mars bin und da ist die Laufzeit so lange, da kann ich nicht vorwärtsfahren, kann kein Joystick nehmen oder ein Roboter fahren.
Viertelstunde Signallaufzeit.
Da muss der Roboter ein Stück weit was autonom können, wobei die Autonomie noch recht eingeschränkt ist. Da kommt man schon drauf, die NASA hat jetzt auch angefangen, mehr solche autonome Funktionen da zu implementieren. Das ist im Prinzip alles auch da, muss man nur erlauben, dass man es einsetzt sozusagen. Da wird viel, also in kleinen Stücken noch exploriert. Da wird ein paar Meter gefahren und dann wird wieder die Situation analysiert und dann wird ein neues Kommando.
Aber das fällt jetzt für dich noch nicht unter Autonomie, wenn man jetzt sagt, fahr mal zehn Meter geradeaus und dann nach links und dann gucken wir nochmal, sondern da geht es eher so darum, wir würden gerne da hinkommen, find doch mal raus.
Genau, also eigentlich würden wir sagen, so was wie wir auf der Landkarte in den Punkt setzen, also wenn ich vom Maß habe ein grobes Geometrie-Modell, da gab es ja schon Missionen, wo man drum geflogen ist und das modelliert hat, und ich weiß meinen Landeplatz und dann gebe ich ein Ziel vor und sage, ich möchte gerne diesen oder jenen Kraterrand fahren und dann soll sich das Roboter-System der Aufgabe stellen und sagen, ich habe lokale Sensorik, also ich kann meine Umgebung wahrnehmen, genauer wie es für mich notwendig ist, wie ich es als Mensch auch mache und sage, hier gibt es Türen, Gänge, Pfade, Wege, unwegsames Gelände, durch Dickicht und so, das würde ich eher vermeiden. Also ich habe eine Sensorik, die das erfasst und dann habe ich eine Geländebewertung, die sagt, komme ich da durch oder nicht, weil ich will natürlich auch den Rover oder den Krabbler nicht verlieren. Und dann versucht er sich sozusagen selbst durchzuschlagen bis dahin. Wenn er in eine Situation kommt, in der er sozusagen kein Regelwerk hat, was er jetzt damit tun soll, dann muss er stehen bleiben und dann brauche ich sozusagen Benutzeranfrage, aber im glücklichsten Fall kommt er dann eben durch. Da gibt es Methoden, die wir hier entwickelt haben für Stereorekonstruktion, jetzt wo man Geländemodelle erzeugt, während man im Gelände sozusagen herumläuft und die Bewertung macht und dann versucht, solche Ziele zu finden. Gibt es auch Arbeiten von anderen Instituten. Das ist aus unserer Sicht die Zukunft, wie man da vorgeht. Das ist dann mehr Autonomie. Was uns auch interessiert ist, wenn man sagt, man hat nicht nur ein System. Wenn ich ein System schicke, dann muss es im Weltraum immer hochredundant sein. Eine interessante Frage aus unserer Sicht ist, kann man Redundanz auch so auflösen, indem man mehrere Systeme schickt? Wenn ich sage, ich kann nicht vielleicht zwei oder drei Systeme, nicht so redundant und nicht so ausfallsicher bauen, aber zum gleichen Preis und vielleicht zum gleichen Gewicht, wie ein einziges, dann habe ich im günstigsten Fall drei Systeme, die parallel was exploren. Und dann möchte ich auch gerne, dass die sich untereinander, wenn sie sich kontakt oder kommunizieren können, dass sie sich absprechen, dass sie also sinnvoll zusammenarbeiten. Und solche Anwendungen haben wir für den Boden auch. Bei so Explorationsszenarien, da gibt es das Thema Search and Rescue. Also wenn man in Katastrophenfällen was machen will, dann hat man vielleicht Fahrzeuge und auch Flugobjekte und dann können die sinnvoll zusammenarbeiten. Das Flugobjekt hat die Übersicht von oben und das Fahrzeug hat eine nähere Sicht, kann auch in Zwischenräume gucken, die man von oben nicht anschauen kann. Wie kombiniert man das dann sinnvoll? Da beginnt es für uns sozusagen interessant autonom zu werden.
Und was auf dem Mars noch so eine Zeitersparnis und damit eine potenzielle Geldersparnis ist, ist dann, darum die Zeitersparnis natürlich bei einer Rettungsmaßnahme auch ein ganz offensichtlicher Vorteil. Da haben wir wieder diese doppelte Bedeutung des selben. Ist denn das ein großes Thema?
Such-and-Rescue mit Robotik? Ja, zurzeit in der Robotik schon. Es wird vor allem adressiert von diesen Flugobjekten, die man hat. Viel mit Hubschraubern, also Octocopter oder Quadrocopter. Relativ kleine Fluggeräte, da gibt es auch von uns Kontakte zur Bergwacht zum Beispiel, wo man sagt, man würde gerne einen Lawinenkegel abfliegen mit einem Sensor und schauen, ob man Piepsignale bekommt oder ob man was sendet, was eine Antwort von einer Skikante gibt als Antenne sozusagen. Dass man da mal eine Vorauswahl trifft, weil man das Problem hat, der erste, der da hinkommt, der alarmiert sozusagen die Mannschaft, kann aber noch nicht ins Feld gehen und sozusagen suchen anfangen, aber man könnte so ein relativ leichtes Flugobjekt suchen lassen. Im Moment ist es im Wesentlichen der Überblick über die Situation, und eine Suche, weil mit so einem Autokopter kann ich wenig machen, und wenn ich jetzt Richtung Mensch gehe, dann müsste ich ja wirklich ordentliche Kräfte aufwenden können. Da sind wir mit unseren Robotersystemen noch nicht so weit.
Also, um die jetzt irgendwie aus dem Schnitt zu ziehen.
Genau, das ist nicht...
Aber finden ist ja, sagen wir mal, überhaupt schon mal das Wichtigste, und damit könnte man natürlich eine Menge Zeit schrinken.
Genau, die Zeit ist halt ein kritischer Faktor. Da muss man relativ schnell sein, und es ist auch die Risikominimierung für die Suchmannschaft. Wenn die ganz gezielt da reingehen können, dann kann man viele Bereiche ausschließen, die vielleicht noch gefährlich sind, weil dann was nachrutscht oder weil irgendwo was noch... Bei Erdbebengebieten habe ich das ja auch. Wenn das Gebäude einsturzgefährdet ist, was macht die Suchmannschaft dann? Das ist schwierig. Da wären natürlich solche Robotersysteme schon sehr hilfreich, die eine Vorauswahl treffen können und sagen können, kann da was sein oder nicht?
Aber sie wären nur hilfreich? Oder gibt es auch schon tatsächlich solche Systeme im Einsatz?
Da arbeiten viele Gruppen dran und das wird wohl auch relativ bald kommen, denke ich. Aber ausgereifte Systeme sehe ich da im Moment noch nicht.
Aber die Nachfrage ist auf jeden Fall schon mal da.
Die Nachfrage ist da, ja. Es wird auch in Japaner denken da viel drüber nach, jetzt nach Fukushima. Da sind sehr viele sehr ernsthaft geworden in der Robotik. Und überlegen, wie sie mit Robotern Systemen tatsächlich unterstützen können.
Was heißt das, sie sind jetzt sehr ernsthaft geworden? Waren sie vorher nicht so ernsthaft?
Doch, ich würde sagen, naja, sie haben sich sehr an der Aufgabe ausgerichtet. Ich meine, wir wissen das gerade in unserem Feld. In Humanoide Robotik sind die Japaner sehr weit, aber es ist alles sehr experimentell. Also es ist sehr forschungsnah. Man schaut, was man alles tun kann, aber es richtet sich nicht nach einer Aufgabe aus. Und da hatten sie halt ein großes Problem jetzt. Und dann war die Frage der Bevölkerung auch, was kann die Robotik dafür tun? Weil das ist natürlich schon eins der Versprechen der Robotik, dass sie da in diesen Fällen helfen kann. Und praktisch ist es natürlich so gewesen, dass man relativ wenig tun konnte. Also gerade die japanischen Systeme waren wenig einsatzfähig. Viel einsatz hat gefunden, militärisches Gerät aus den USA.
Was deutlich mehr gegen Stör-Einflüsse und Tiefhördeaktivität.
Die haben sich daran ausgerichtet, was muss ich alles aushalten können, sozusagen? Und welche Grundfunktionen kann ich da noch durchführen? Also eigentlich auch nur die Lageeinschätzung. Ich komme irgendwo rein und sehe, was da ist. Nicht, dass ich wirklich aufräume. Da hat man eben festgestellt, dass viele Dinge ganz schön am Bedarf vorbeigehen. Der Humanoide-Roboter, der da herumsteigt, das ist ganz nett, aber da kann er nichts tun. Die haben dann auch festgestellt, im Nachgang, ein schweres Gerät braucht man, Lastwagen, Bagger und so weiter. Und die muss man fernsteuern können. Die hat man nicht vorgehalten. Und dann kommt jetzt schon wieder der Humanoide rein. Und dann sagt man ja, wie soll es denn langfristig aussehen? Halt ich dann lauter fernsteuerbare Bagger vor. Das ist ja relativ teuer. Oder kann ich ein Robotersystem reinsetzen und einen Bagger nehmen, den es eh schon gibt? Die Bagger hatten sie genug, aber sie konnten halt keinen Menschen da reinschicken wegen der Strahlung. Und dann hat man im Umkehrschluss das schon wieder. Aber dann hat man ganz andere Anforderungen, was der können muss. Und er muss eben auch fernsteuerbar sein. Das freut uns wieder, weil wir von Anfang an, wir kommen daher und wir haben das nie aufgegeben. Wir haben gesagt, eigentlich muss man ohne große Schaltvorgänge zwischen vollständig autonom und vollständig teleoperiert jederzeit wechseln können. Das heißt, wenn es notwendig ist, soll der menschliche Operator sich auf den Roboter schalten können. Und wenn er das für unwichtig hält, dann soll der Roboter das alleine weitermachen können. Die Fähigkeit ist weiterhin wichtig, weil wie soll ich eine Lageeinschätzung von einer Situation, die für den Menschen auch völlig neu ist, durch den Roboter vornehmen lassen. Das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass man da zu schnellen Lösungen kommt. Das heißt, ich will eigentlich einen Menschen mit möglichst allen Sinnen möglichst nah vor Ort haben, ohne dass ihm was passiert, sodass ich seinen Hirn und seine Einschätzung der Lage nutzen kann. Und da, glaube ich, werden wir in den nächsten Jahren viel sehen, weil die Japaner das sehr ernst nehmen. Also das ist für sie, glaube ich, eine richtig nationale Aufgabe. Das haben wir bei vielen Robotikkonferenzen jetzt von hochrangigen Wissenschaftlern gesehen, dass die sehr ernsthaft und sehr nachhaltig über das Problem nachdenken. Das ist eine Art und Weise, wie die Gesellschaft damit umgeht jetzt.
Ja, vorher war es ja immer so ein bisschen der japanische Traum, so vor allem so die Haushaltshilfe und den Pfleger zum Lebensabend etc. Das sind zumindest immer die Bilder, die man gesehen hat. Natürlich dann auch häufig so das Nachbilden des menschlichen Körpers, also möglichst so Humanoid wie möglich zu sein. In Aussehen, Reaktionen, Emotionen. Und jetzt geht es hin zur Katastrophe.
Ich denke, dass die Ausrichtung Richtung Humanoid und zu Hause bleibt. Aber was wir in Europa nie recht nachvollziehen konnten, ist dieser Begleiter, also der Partner-Roboter. Das sehen wir ganz anders. Also ein Roboter ist für uns eine Maschine, für uns hier am DLR auch. Das ist nichts, was ich... Kein Freund. Und in Japan hat es gereicht. Auch viele Sachen sahen ja wie Spielzeuge aus. Das ist ein nettes Spielzeug. Und es ist akzeptiert, dass man das im Haushalt hat. Das würde hier nie jemand akzeptieren. Und das wird wahrscheinlich weniger werden. Aber diese Vorstellung, dass man da sozusagen die Haushaltshilfe hat, die hegen wir natürlich auch. Dass man das nur relativ weit ist, im Haushalt ist es relativ schwierig. Weil die Aufgaben sind vielfältig. Und viele Dinge, die ein Roboter vielleicht machen könnte, die sind schon automatisiert. Also wenn man sich überlegt, was wir alles an technischen Hilfsmitteln, Waschmaschine, Spülmaschine, Staubsauger im Haushalt haben, dann sind viele Dinge, die technisch lösbar sind und automatisierbar sind, schon gelöst. Das heißt, das ist jetzt nur mehr die Schnittstelle zwischen diesen Geräten und das große Aufräumen sozusagen vom Roboter zu erledigen. Und wie soll der Roboter wissen, wie ich meinen Haushalt organisieren und aufräumen soll, wenn ich selber nicht weiß?
Vielleicht muss da jeder erstmal bei sich selber anfangen.
Das ist, glaube ich, eine schwierige Frage.
Ja, ist es. Na ja gut, dann muss man vielleicht doch dazu übergehen, jedes Spielzeug mit einem RFID-Chip auszustatten.
Genau, aber dann ist die Frage, ob ich es noch finde. Also ich organisiere mir, dann ist die Frage, ob ich dem Roboter das überlasse, wie meine Umwelt organisiert ist. Ich würde es nicht wollen.
Ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht, aber man darf ja noch träumen. Diese ganzen Überlegungen, jetzt Autonomie, Fernprogrammierung und so weiter haben jetzt hier zu einer Liste von Schwerpunkten geführt. Teilweise klang es ja hier schon an. Also es geht jetzt gar nicht so sehr darum, den Menschen nachzubilden. Das ist jetzt hier nicht im einigen Sinne das Ziel, da mit Metropolis-Style eine Kopie des Menschen zu schaffen. Trotz alledem orientiert man sich natürlich zwangsläufig an den Menschen, weil wir einfach so universell sind und Universalität geht es ja. Das hat sich da mit dem Greifen ja schon sehr deutlich gezeigt. So etwas wie die Hand ist ja als Ergebnis Jahrtausender, Jahrhunderttausende, Millionen von Jahren von Evolution sozusagen ein perfektes Instrument, um eben Dinge zu tun. Was sind jetzt hier so diese daraus abgeleiteten Ideen, wofür man die Robotik jetzt noch vor allem zum Einsatz bringen kann und noch in der Zukunft können sollte?
Also das Fernziel ist natürlich, dass wir eine ähnliche Flexibilität erreichen, wie sie der Mensch hat mit seinen Armen und Händen. Da sind wir im Moment relativ weit weg noch. Und wir wissen es aber, wir sehen es ja Menschen, was man alles tun kann damit. Das ist natürlich immer ein Antrieb zu verstehen, wie wir das machen, auf welche Weise das passiert, wie wir das lernen und wie wir das technisch nachbilden können. Das ist eine Grundfrage, die uns interessiert. Jetzt kann man sich überlegen, warum sind wir überhaupt auf Hände gekommen am Anfang und auf Arme. Das kommt jetzt wieder mit der Fernprogrammierung. Wenn ich die Autonomie nicht habe, dann ist eine Möglichkeit oder die erste einfache Möglichkeit, die in Betriebnahme und des Tests, ob eine neue Hardware den Erwartungen entspricht, die direkte Fernsteuerung. Da hat man vor zehn Jahren viel Datenhandschuhsteuerung gesehen. Tracking-Systeme sind entwickelt worden, erst mit magnetischen Verfahren und dann mit optischen Verfahren. Mit Tracking-Markern, die sind immer kleiner geworden. So dass ich, indem ich mich bewege und meine Hand bewege und meine Arme bewege, den Roboter steuern kann. Und je näher der Roboter an dem menschlichen Vorbild ist, also wenn die Kinematik gleich ist, also ich auch sieben Achsen habe am Arm und ich ähnliche Fingeranordnung habe und ähnliche Freiheitsgrade an den Fingern, dann kann ich den Roboter relativ leicht direkt fernsteuern. Und dann kann ich relativ komplizierte Aufgaben machen. Das ist, was wir Telepräsenzsteuerung nennen. Das ist eine möglichst eins-zu-eins-Kopplung meiner Bewegung auf den Roboter. Und dann brauch ich noch ein Feedback, also Kamerabilder sozusagen, damit ich sehe, was das Objekt und der Roboter macht. Und wenn möglich auch eine Kraftinformation. Wir haben auch festgestellt, Akustik ist gut, ist im Weltraum ein bisschen schwierig, weil da ist keine Luft da, gibt es Schallwellenprobleme. Aber da haben wir also festgestellt, was ist eine gute Mimik, um rückzukoppeln, ob das funktioniert oder nicht. Und da haben wir angefangen mit ESDN-Leitungen über größere Entfernungen und so weiter. Das war schon in der Zeit, als ich angefangen hab. Und da kann man relativ komplizierte Sachen machen. Wir haben so Steckbretter für Weltraummuster, wo wir so Bayonett-Stecker abziehen, was wir autonom nicht können. Aber wo wir sehen, die Hardware kann das. Das ist so der erste Check sozusagen. Was liefert mir, was kann die Hardware im Prinzip? Und dann ist die andere Frage, was davon kann ich jetzt automatisieren? Deswegen ist es nah am Menschen oder Menschen ähnlich, erstmal einfacher überhaupt was zu zeigen, wenn das ganz anders aussieht, dann geht dieses 1 zu 1 Mapping nicht mehr, dann muss ich irgendwas lernen, da wird es wesentlich komplizierter. Auch rauszufinden, kann ich es jetzt nur nicht, weil ich nicht trainiert bin, oder weil es prinzipiell nicht geht, dann muss ich methodisch herangehen. Und dann stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie erreiche ich jetzt die Leistungsfähigkeit von dieser Fernsteuerung auch autonom? Also was für Griffe muss ich da planen, wie fahre ich die Finger zusammen und was für Regelungen brauche ich? Das ist auch ein großes Problem. Wir haben ja die Roboter so gebaut, dass sie nachgiebig regelbar sind, dass ich in Kontakt mit der Umwelt gehen kann und dass ich die Federsteifigkeit, mit der ich zupacke, variieren kann. Also ich kann ganz weiche Finger haben. Wir haben mal gesagt, wenn man eine Tomate greifen will. Und dann kann ich sie auch relativ hart machen. Je steifer ich die Finger mache, desto präziser kann ich die Position steuern. Und je weicher ich sie mache, desto leichter umschließen sie Objekte. Jetzt ist die Frage, welche Steifigkeit für welche Art der Anwendung? Brauche ich irgendwie ein Modell für die Art des Vorgangs? Und dann suchen wir uns mal so beispielhafte Vorgänge aus. Zum Beispiel wenn man Richtung Assembly, das ist der Zusammenbau von Dingen geht, dann habe ich oft Fügeaufgaben. Und da gibt es schon lange Fügeaufgaben. Ich füge einen Teil in ein anderes. Das ist eine grundsätzliche Dinge. So Lego-Verstörung sozusagen. Lego-Teile zusammenbauen, oder man hat so Steckbretter. Also relativ einfach. Und dann, wenn man sich überlegt, man hat lange mit diesem Zylinder als klassisches Pack-and-Hold-Problem. Man fügt einen Zylinder ein. Wie macht man das? Was braucht man da für Informationen? Visuelle, wo bin ich und wie sieht meine Kraft aus? Dann hat man lange versucht aus den Kraftinformationen, den Status der Kontaktsituation zu schätzen und das dann automatisch zu machen. Das ist relativ schwierig, wenn man auf nur einem Kanal das machen will. Man muss die irgendwie fusionieren.
Was wir jetzt festgestellt haben...
Was heißt das auf einem Kanal? Ich nehme nur Vision, also ich nehme nur, was ich sehe, die visuelle Information, ohne dass die Kräfte irgendwie sind. Dann habe ich das Problem, wenn ich da einfüge, dann sind mir Teile nicht sichtbar. Und wenn ich die Kraftinformation habe, dann muss ich eigentlich immer eine Historie anschauen. Also das heißt, an einem Punkt, wenn ich bin und mir die Kräfte angucke, dann sehe ich da eigentlich relativ wenig. Das heißt, es geht nur über einen gewissen Zeitraum und dann brauche ich, was wir State Estimation nennen, wir brauchen irgendwie eine Kontaktzustandschätzung. Das ist relativ schwierig, aus diesen Signalen rauszubekommen.
Aber wenn man beides kombiniert, setzt es schon wieder anders aus.
Dann sieht es anders aus, ist aber auch aus unserer Sicht immer noch ungelöst. Und dann kann man sich überlegen, es gibt Beispiele, die Kollegen programmiert haben, die ohne Sensorfeedback funktionieren und die viel robuster sind, als wenn ich einfach hingehe und das mache und dann stellt man fest, man hat bei so einer Aufgabe eigentlich zwei Teile. Das eine, was der Mensch hat, ist, er hat einen guten Plan, wie er es machen will. Also irgendwie hat er gelernt, dass es einen robusten Plan gibt. Und dann führt er ihn aus und während der Ausführung versucht er sozusagen über die Signale, die er an den Fingern empfängt und was er sieht, das zu korrigieren. Und jetzt kann ich dann noch den dritten Schritt machen und sagen, wenn ich meinen Plan so ausrichte, dass ich Kontaktzustände sicher erreiche, die ich gut detektieren kann, dann bin ich sozusagen doppelt robust. Und dann versucht man, Modelle zu finden, wie man das machen kann. Beim Fügen ist es, wenn man es zweite macht, relativ einfach, dass man feststellen kann, man muss sich an der Geometrie orientieren. Die dieses Teil hat. Es gibt Regionen, in denen kann ich mich sozusagen am Rand von einer Kontur selber in dieses Loch führen lassen. Und an anderen Ecken und Enden geht es nicht. Also wenn sie ganz parallel versuchen, was von oben irgendwo draufzusetzen, den Legostein zum Beispiel, dann wird es meistens nicht klappen. Sie setzen den Legostein schräg an.
Dass man so ein bisschen ankantet.
Genau, man hat so eine Führung. Und dann, wenn man das Gefühl hat, jetzt ist fix, dann drehen sie ihn nach oben, dann liegt er parallel und dann drücken sie drauf.
So eine Anlegekante. Aber einen Rückkanal braucht man natürlich trotzdem.
Genau, dann brauch ich einen Rückkanal. Aber das muss alles zusammenspielen. Wenn ich einen Teil weglasse, wird es unnötig schwierig. Die Vorstellung war am Anfang halt, dass man sagt, man hat den Rückkanal und damit ist es gelöst. Damit hat man aber das Problem noch nicht ganz verstanden. Weil natürlich ist es so, wenn man den Menschen anschaut und sagt, man macht was zum ersten Mal, dann braucht man länger. Und es klappt auch nicht immer. Und wenn man in etwas Übung kriegt, dann macht man implizit, ohne dass man genau weiß, was man tut, hat man ein bestimmtes Modell, nach dem man vorgeht. Das ist einfach eine Vorausschätzung. Ich sag, so ist dieses Ding und ich hab eine gewisse Erfahrung und die Trajektorie wende ich jetzt an und dann werde ich das Feedback aus. Und das am Roboter muss ich ihn entweder auch lernen lassen, was schwierig ist, weil er so viele Eingangsmöglichkeiten hat, oder ich gebe ihm ein Modell mit. Für den Weltraum kommt meistens das Modell nur in Frage, weil ich dann genauer weiß, was sich da abspielt. Aber das sind auch Fragen, die wir dann beantworten müssen. Wie sehen solche Modelle aus?
Ganz konkret sehen die Modelle ja hier so aus. Es gibt hier den Justin. Das nimmt man häufig so als einen Roboter wahr. Tatsächlich gibt es da mehrere von, die so eine ähnliche Optik haben. Man kann hier eher von einer Roboter-Robotik-Plattform sprechen. Aber das ist so ein Vogel mit etwas verdrehten Armen. So sieht es zumindest auf den ersten Blick aus. Mit so Mickey-Maus-Händen, also auch nur die vorhin schon beschriebenen Vierfinger-Hände. Was hat denn zu der Entwicklung dieser Justin-Serie geführt? Am Anfang waren es nur Teilexperimente. Dann hat man irgendwann gesagt, jetzt machen wir den großen Wurf.
Nein, wir gehen selten her und sagen, wir machen den großen Wurf.
Nein, wirklich nicht. Es sind immer kleine Schritte.
Wir wollen den nächsten Schritt machen. Wir haben schon ein klares Ziel, wo wir hinwollen. Aber dass man sagt, man macht jetzt den großen Wurf, das ist hohes Risiko und die Systeme sind dann auch entsprechend teuer. Aber wir haben Arme und Hände entwickelt und wir konnten diese Arme und Hände telepräsent zeigen, also ferngesteuert. Das erste, was wir natürlich wollten, ich komme aus der Informatik und habe gesagt, es muss auch irgendwie selbstständig gehen. In der Industrie macht der Roboter auch alles alleine. Das muss mit unserem Roboter auch gehen. Und dann haben wir ihn fix in ein solches Weltraum-Mockup geschraubt und haben dann angefangen, autonom Sachen zu machen. Also erstmal geteached und dann mit Bildverarbeitung.
Was heißt denn ein Raumfahrt-Mockup?
Damals war das so, wir kamen sozusagen auf die Idee mit den Armen über ein Experiment 93Rotex, haben einen Weltraum-Roboter ferngesteuert. Da war so eine Work-Cell und sowas hatte man danach gebildet. Wie sieht das Spacelab-Labor aus? Was für Schubladen, was für Bedieneinheiten gibt es da? Das sollte der Roboter automatisiert Experimente durchführen können. Das hatten wir im Labor. Dann war das erste sind so einfache Aufgaben. Dann haben wir gesagt, wir wollen eigentlich Bildverarbeitung dazu haben. Das heißt, wir wollen Objekte, die flexibel irgendwo sind, am Tisch stehen, lokalisieren und mit denen was machen. Die erste einfache Aufgabe war eigentlich, weil wir das auch teleoperiert oft vorgeführt haben, wir schenken irgendwie ein Getränk ein. Wir schrauben eine Wasserflasche auf und füllen dann ein Glas und können das Glas dann sozusagen anreichen. Da haben wir ein System gebaut, auch mit einer mobilen Plattform. Das hieß der Robattler. Also der robotische Battler. Und der konnte das. Das haben wir dann auch 2004 auf einer Messe vorgeführt. Und da hat man dann deutlich gesehen, was für Limits man hat mit einer Hand. Nämlich, wenn man eine Flasche aufschrauben will, dann muss der Deckel sehr lose sein, dass man den sozusagen mit den Fingern in einer Schraubbewegung losbekommt, wenn man keine zweite Hand hat, um die Flasche zu fixieren. Und wenn man alle Objekte, die man am Tisch liegen hat oder die in Haushaltsumgebungen vorkommen und lose sind, sind schwierig zu manipulieren, weil die nicht fixiert sind. In dem Raumfahrt-Mockup ist alles fixiert, weil sonst würde das ja frei im Raum herumfliegen und die Anforderungen hat man nicht. Das heißt, für die Anforderungen wäre ein Arm ausreichend gewesen, aber für die Erdanwendungen nicht. Und dann kommen auch immer so technische Faktoren dazu. Wir hatten die ganzen Systeme unabhängig voneinander geplant. Also die Hand war ein System, hatte ihren eigenen Rechner, der in einer Hardware ausgeführt war, die man hätte auch im Weltraum fliegen können. Der Arm hatte seinen eigenen, die Plattform hatte seinen eigenen, und die Bildverarbeitung hatte den eigenen, und die Bewegungsplanung auch. Und dann gab es noch eine Fernsteuereinheit. Und dann hatte man also einen Haufen verschiedene Systeme zusammengesammelt, und die hat man bauchkastenartig zusammengesteckt, ohne dass man vorher darauf geachtet hat, dass man so etwas wie eine Schnittstelle wie beim Legoteil hat, dass das Ganze auch zusammenpasst. Das heißt, es war eigentlich ziemlich furchtbar zu betreiben. Es ging, aber wir waren uns alle klar, also alle, die beteiligt waren, waren sich klar darüber, dass wenn das System jetzt komplizierter würde und man hat sich einen zweiten Arm gewünscht, dass man es so nicht mehr machen kann. Und dann hat man als Allererstes angefangen, die ganze Steuerung umzukrempeln und gesagt, wir nehmen den einen, den Robotler, der war auf einer mobilen Plattform, und den anderen im Mockup. Wir hatten zwei Arme, zwei Hände.
Also mobile Plattform heißt, mit Rädern durch die Gegend fahren.
Genau, konnte er fahren. Und die hat man gegenübergestellt.
Das ist doch schon wieder das japanische Modell, der Begleiter, der die ganze Zeit die Trinks einschüttet.
Ja, war auch ein großes Projekt, hieß Dirocol. Das war der Roboter für den Medizinbereich, also Hohl- und Bringdienst im Krankenhaus. Essen bringen und verteilen für Patienten und Glutkonserven holen und solche Sachen gab es da auch schon.
Das waren jetzt alles so Forschungs-, Anwendungsideen, wo jetzt die Krankenhäuser schon auf der Schwelle standen und sagten, wir brauchen das jetzt mal schnell.
Ja, da gab es schon auch Anwender, die gesagt haben, sie brauchen das. Die Anforderungen hat man heute auch. Das präzisiert sich dann über die Jahre. Also die Anforderungen am Anfang hieß dann auch, wir fahren da Patienten in der Gegend herum. Davon kommt man ab, aber wir haben jetzt wieder die Anfrage bekommen, und zwar, wenn man ins Krankenhaus geht, dann hat man irgendwo eine Untersuchung und dann wird man zum Röntgen oder zum CT oder sonst wo hin geschickt. In großen Krankenhäusern sind das weite Wege und die Leute sind ja aufgeregt, weil irgendwas ist ja nicht in Ordnung und das ist ein großes Krankenhaus und verunsichert. Und dann gehen die häufig verloren im Krankenhaus. Also die werden irgendwo hingeschickt, aber tauchen dort nie auf.
Ach so, wenn sie selber dahin gehen sollen.
Genau, sonst muss ich ja jemanden mitschicken sozusagen. Dann wäre es der Roboter, der weiß, der sich im Krankenhaus auskennt und sagt, ich führ dich jetzt dahin, nehme dich sozusagen bei der Hand. Ja, sonst muss ich eine Krankenschwester mitschicken.
Das ist relativ teuer.
Aber da gibt es schon Anwendungen. Gab es damals auch, aber natürlich in der Ausprägung war das nicht so. Und die Plattform haben wir dann genutzt und die zwei Robotersysteme gegenübergestellt und gesagt, okay, wir klemmen das jetzt alles ab, machen die ganze Steuerung und Regelung neu und versuchen, was kann man mit zwei Armen und Nachgiebigkeit machen? Und dann haben wir da große Eimer gegriffen und über diese Federsteifigkeiten sozusagen zusammengedrückt. Also echte zweiarmige Manipulation mit richtigen Feedback-Control Loops, was sehr robust funktioniert hat. Auch Hände geschüttelt haben wir und so die Steuerung implementiert. Und waren uns sicher, dass wir so ein System beherrschen würden, wenn wir es denn bauen. Und dann gab es eine Diplomarbeit, die hat dann den Torso konstruiert. Da ist also an die zwei Arme, wenn man den Arbeitsraum anschaut, also schaut, wo kann der Roboter überall hinfahren mit der Hand und wie sieht es dann aus, wenn man zwei machen würden? Wie groß ist der? Kann man am Tisch, am Boden und ins Rekal greifen? Das war so die Zielvorstellung. Dann sieht man, dass man zusätzliche Freiheitsgrade braucht, also Beweglichkeiten. So etwas wie wir haben ein Tor, so dass wir uns ein bisschen bewegen können. Und den haben wir dann projektiert und zusammengebaut. 2006 auf der Automatica in München, das ist eine Automatisierungsmesse, haben wir den zum ersten Mal gezeigt. Da konnte er sich im Wesentlichen bewegen, aber es war...
Das ist jetzt schon das Modell, das als Justin dann bekannt wurde?
Das hieß Justin, genau. Und ist aber auf einem Tisch montiert gewesen.
Heißt das eigentlich irgendwas?
Da verbirgt sich auch was ganz Tolles. Der ist Justin genannt, weil er ist Justin Time fertig geworden. Und vorher gab es keine anderen Namen. Wir haben lange überlegt, wie es heißt. Wir sind mit den Prospekten auf die Messe gegangen und haben gesagt, das ist das Zweiarmsystem. Weil wir keinen rechten Namen gefunden haben. Es gab welche, die haben es Arnold nennen wollen, und Claudia und alle möglichen Vorschläge gab es da. Es hat aber keine so recht allen gepasst. Der Herr Hirtzinger, der Chef damals, hat gesagt, ein System ohne Namen geht nicht. Es wird immer noch geschraubt. Die Messeleitung hatte schon gesagt, wir begrüßen sie. Die Messe geht jetzt los. Wir haben noch die letzten Teile hin montiert. Dann hat er gesagt, der heißt Justin, weil er wird hoffentlich noch Justin Time fertig. Dann war das auch so. Das heißt, wir hatten...
Interessante Namensfindungen. Wenn man danach gehen würde, würde wahrscheinlich fast jedes Projekt Justin heißen.
Was man natürlich suchen muss, ist, wir sind international. Das heißt, es ist viel englischsprachig. Man muss einen Namen finden, der für die Engländer auch funktioniert. Sonst hat man oft Probleme, dass die ganz komisch interpretiert werden.
Aber das war jetzt schon ein relativ humanoid daherkommendes System. Hat auch einen Kopf, einen Tor, Arme dran, auch mit Schulter, Ellenbogen, Gelenken. Die, und das meinte ich vorhin mit verdreht, mechanische Drehgelenke sind, die jetzt nicht unbedingt daraufhin optimiert sind, genauso auszusehen wie ein Mensch, sondern sich einfach nur an denselben Stellen befinden und eine Drehbewegung dann herbeiführen können.
Also die Zielsetzung von dem System war erstmal überhaupt nicht, das Menschen ähnlich zu machen, sondern wirklich, wie ich gesagt habe, wir wollten einen zweiten Arm haben. Die Arme waren ja schon fertig, also die Arme waren gegeben. Die Gelenkmodule vom Leichtbau-Roboter waren, wie sie waren. Die sind knubbelig und so gemacht, dass man mit den Fingern nicht hineinfassen kann in diese Bewegung. Also vorher hatten wir so Kästen, die da schwenken und dann kann man sich quetschen. Und die Idee war immer, wir haben ja die Drehmomentsensorik, das heißt, der Roboter ist sehr sensibel auf Berührung von außen. Das heißt, ich kann ihn hinfassen und ihn bewegen und irgendwo in eine andere Position bringen. Ich kann auch Kontakte detektieren. Und wenn ich das habe, dann muss ich darauf achten, dass ich nicht unabsichtlich irgendwo Problemzonen schaffe, wenn der Mensch ihn anfasst. Verstehe, ein Sicherheitsaspekt. Deswegen ist der so rund. Der Vorgänger von dem Roboter hatte so schwarze Kästen. Und da gab es zwei Stellen, wo man die Finger reinkriegen konnte. Und dann wären die abgequetscht worden. Das ging also gar nicht. Das waren so Gabeln, da hätte man richtig abscheren können. Und deswegen sieht der Roboter so aus. Der Arm hat 7 Achsen. Das heißt, der ist redundant ausgelegt. Und der menschliche Arm hat es auch. Das kann man ganz einfach ausprobieren. Man fasst irgendwo hin oder hält das Handgelenk steif. Und dann kann man den Ellbogen ein Stück bewegen. Das heißt, wir brauchen nicht alle unserer Freiheitsgrade, um eine bestimmte Position im Raum einzunehmen. Das hatte der Roboter auch. Das war von Anfang an die Überlegung, dass man sagt, wenn der mehr Menschen arbeitet, dann kann ich ihn immer noch ein bisschen wegschieben. Und ich habe mehr Flexibilität. Aber die Arme waren eigentlich so fertig. Und dann haben wir gesagt, wenn wir jetzt zwei aneinander oder nebeneinander bauen, dann sollen die einen gewissen Überlappungsbereich haben. Sonst kann ich ja nachher wieder nicht aufschrauben oder sowas machen. Und gleichzeitig aber einen größeren Raum abdecken. Deswegen sind sie jetzt nicht total überschneidend im Arbeitsraum, sondern so ähnlich wie der Mensch. Aber die Herangehensweise war eine rein technische. Wir haben uns angeschaut, die Arbeitsraumvolumen, und wie muss man es anordnen. Und dann haben sie vorhin angesprochen, man sieht so, dass der so Schultern hat und Ellbogen. Weil die Schulter kommen daher, dass der Roboter nicht gerade aus der Seite rauskommt, sondern so schräg nach oben gerichtet ist und dann da eben eine Drehachse hat. Das hat auch technische Hintergründe. Wenn man die senkrecht zur Tischebene raus hat, also in rechten Winkeln hat, dann kriegt man Probleme mit Singularitäten im Arbeitsraum. Die sind dann immer genau da, wo man manipulieren will. Singularität im Arbeitsraum heißt, dass ich aus einer bestimmten Position nicht einfach in jede Richtung mich wegbewegen kann. Das heißt, es kann sein, dass der Roboter sich umkonfigurieren muss. Dann fährt er ein großes Stück oder mit hoher Geschwindigkeit, um eine ganz kleine Bewegung an der Fingerspitze zu machen. Das versucht man zu vermeiden. Wenn man da kathesisch durchfahren will, hat man ein Problem. Da braucht man spezielle Methoden. Man kann direkt exakt da gar nicht durchfahren, sondern muss ein Stück vorbei fahren, also ein bisschen von der Bahn abweichen. Das war so eine Überlegung, dass wir die Singularitäten aus dem bevorzugten Arbeitsbereich, den wir da haben, raushalten. Deswegen kommt die Schulter zustande. Dann hat man sich überlegt und gesagt, so etwas wie ein Ellbogen ist natürlich gut. Wie sieht die Lage aus? Dann ist der Roboter auch immer so, der steht so da, dass die Ellbogen nach außen sind. Der könnte auch anders da stehen, dann sehr viel weniger menschenähnlich aus. Man hat aber das Problem, dass man Eigenkollisionen und so etwas hat. Wenn man den Roboter anschaut, sieht man auch, dass er eine sehr schmale Brustpartie oder so eine Taille hat. Das liegt daran, dass wir die Gelenkwinkelgrenzen von dem Roboter so gelegt haben, dass er sich sozusagen mit dem Ellbogen nicht selber kollidieren kann. Dass ich sozusagen in mich hinein mechanisch gar nicht fahren kann. Dann brauche ich auch keine Software, die das verhindert. Ich kann natürlich mit den Händen gegeneinander fahren, das muss ich dann verhindern, aber der Rest ist erstmal ausgeschlossen.
Verstehe. Das heißt, die ganzen Zwänge, die letztlich zu diesem Design geführt haben, waren eigentlich technische, sicherheitstechnische Zwänge, aber am Ende kommt man dann doch wieder bei einer Ähnlichkeit raus, obwohl man ja auch aufgenommen hätte, dass es vielleicht nicht so ähnlich ist, damit es komplex wird.
Zu der Zeit hatten wir auch noch keine Werkzeuge, um uns das irgendwie anschaulich zu visualisieren. Was ist dann wirklich die Ähnlichkeit? Wir haben das später mal untersucht, weil wir die Arme auch einsetzen, um Kraftfeedback zu machen, also so Kräfte zurückzukoppeln. Dann fasst man sozusagen den Arm am Ende an und steuert ihn herum. Und wenn man irgendwo was spürt, also eine Gegenkraft spürt, dann soll der Arm einen sozusagen diese Gegenkraft reflektieren. Und da möchte man auch einen möglichst großen Arbeitsraum abdecken und dann musste man untersuchen, wie sieht denn der menschliche Arbeitsraum aus? Und da gibt es eher Ergonomie- Untersuchungen, die solche Visualisierungen machen. Wir haben das dann auch mal ausgerechnet anhand von Skelettmodellen. Was bedeutet das für uns technisch und das Verglichen mit dem Arbeitsraum, den der Roboter kann? Und dann festgestellt, dass unser Leichtbau-Roboter einen größeren Arbeitsraum hat, was nicht verwunderlich ist, weil der kann an verschiedenen Achsen eben 180 Grad durchdrehen. Das kann der menschliche Arm mit den wenigsten. Und dann festgestellt, dass wenn wir den Roboterarm einschränken künstlich auf die Konfigurationen, die der Mensch auch kann, dass wir die meisten Aufgaben trotzdem noch lösen können und immer eine natürliche Haltung haben dann. Da gibt es viele, die untersuchen und sagen, wenn der Mensch mit dem Roboter zusammen arbeitet, dann soll er möglichst menschenähnlich sein, damit ich mich sicher fühle. Das ist für uns jetzt nicht der Hauptantrieb. Aber die Frage war schon, was schränke ich mir ein oder wie viele Aufgaben kann ich wirklich noch lösen? Und brauche ich diese Freiheiten überhaupt von dem Roboter? Und wir haben einfach mal künstlich eingeschränkt und gesagt, wir nehmen jetzt nur noch Konfigurationen, die menschenähnlich sind oder die ergonomisch sind für den Menschen und kann ich es dann immer noch lösen, das Problem. Und das ist in der Tat so. Und man hat dann auch das Gefühl, komischerweise oder natürlicherweise, dass der Roboter viel intelligenter agiert, weil es so aussieht, wie wenn es ein Gegenüber macht. Wobei das natürlich nichts mit Intelligenz zu tun hat, sondern das ist nur unsere Wahrnehmung. Wir interpretieren da irgendwas rein. Das stellen wir auch oft fest jetzt. Deswegen ist auch, glaube ich, der Justin so erfolgreich, weil unten heißt er auch bei manchen, hat so ein Herz drum hängen, die Prinzessin. Man interpretiert doch immer was rein in die Maschine, obwohl wir immer sagen, es ist eine Maschine.
Ich glaube, wir wollen auch immer so ein bisschen Bezug dazu haben und etwas, was uns ähnlich ist. Da erwartet man in gewisser Hinsicht ja dann auch eben ein ähnliches Verhalten, etc.
Genau. Aber was für uns auch, was wir festgestellt haben, was in den Experimenten mit der Maschine wichtig ist, ist wenigstens ein deterministisches Verhalten. Also wir haben ja in der Robotik jetzt, wenn man Richtung Bewegungsplanung geht, ich habe mal angefangen mit Griffplanung, zufallsbasiert. Da gibt es sehr viele Methoden für Geometrieplanung, die auf zufallsbasierten Ansätzen funktionieren, die schnell gehen, die aber irgendeine Lösung liefern, die also keine Präferenz haben und wo es jedes Mal anders aussieht. Das ist echt schwierig für den, der auch dort steht, weil er dann nicht weiß, ist es jetzt noch ein sinnvoller Fall oder tritt hier irgendein Fehler auf. Ich weiß dann nicht, ist der Roboter im Plan. Solange ich nachvollziehen kann, dass das sozusagen in der Bahn ist oder in dem Bereich, was ich erwarte und was sinnvoll ist, da kann ich den Roboter laufen lassen und wenn irgendwas anderes passiert, dann muss ich ihn irgendwie stoppen oder eingreifen. Für den, der demonstriert oder der mit dem Roboter umgeht, tatsächlich ein ziemlicher Stressfaktor, wenn er gar nicht weiß, was als nächstes passiert. Wenn er plötzlich irgendwelche Bewegungen macht, die rein zufallsbasiert sind und da irgendwo hinfährt. Das ist auch ein Faktor, wo man sagt, okay, für Weltraumanwendung kommt das nicht in Frage, weil da ist eh schon Stress. Da braucht der Astronaut nicht noch irgendein wahnsinniges Gerät, das dann irgendwelche Dinge da treibt. Das muss man schon berücksichtigen, aber das sozusagen als Hauptziel zu machen, da ist für uns die Funktion schon immer noch wichtiger.
Aber inwiefern ist denn jetzt diese eine wirkliche Intelligenz erforderlich, insbesondere im Hinblick auf die wünschenswerte Autonomie? Also, kommt man da so mit reiner Algorithmik und dem Zahlenspiel? Kommt man da irgendwie zurecht? Oder ist nicht ein Großteil der Autonomie, die wir erwarten, also wenn ich jetzt an sowas wie ein Maßrover halt denke, der eben jetzt selber rauskriegen soll, wie er da in den Krater reinfahren soll und um diesen Stein herumkommt, reicht da so eine reine Berechnungsansatz, so im Sinne von, naja, rechne mal aus, was wir sonst hier bei uns ausrechnen würden, nachdem wir uns die Bilder angeschaut haben? Oder ist da wirklich ein Lernen, ein adaptives Erfassen, so wie man das eben, so eine kognitive Wahrnehmung, läuft es darauf hinaus oder geht es doch anders?
Das kommt immer auf den Aufwand an, mit dem man die einzelnen Probleme angeht, denke ich. Also die Zielsetzung oder die Vorstellung ist schon, dass man irgendwann kognitivere Ansätze, wie auch immer die dann aussehen, einsetzen möchte, um mehr Allgemeingültigkeit zu haben und auf Situationen flexibler reagieren zu können. Im Moment sind die Sachen sehr eingeschränkt auf ganz einfache Dinge. Also ich würde mal sagen, Basiskognition ist das dann. Relativ einfache Dinge. Und die Reparaturarbeiten, die wir zum Beispiel im Weltraum adressieren, sind doch schon deutlich komplizierter. Das heißt, wir haben da eine Lücke. Das heißt, wir gehen oft vor und versuchen, Modelle zu finden, die das stützen können. Ich meine, wenn man KI-Methoden anschaut, dann sagt man, man hat Entscheidungsmodelle oder Algorithmen, die versuchen...
Also KI, künstliche Intelligenz.
Künstliche Intelligenz. Das andere sind die Lehrenverfahren. Künstliche Intelligenz versucht immer, in diskreten Strukturen Lösungswege zu finden. Und die Frage ist, wie groß ist dieser State Space, in dem ich suchen muss? Das ist das Hauptproblem. Und wenn ich Modelle habe als Vorabinformation, die ich da hineinbaue, dann kann ich den Suchraum sinnvoll einschränken und dann finde ich vielleicht schneller Lösungen. Das ist mal einfach, um so ein Planungsproblem zu lösen. Dann kann ich Situationen bewerten, mehr Situationen bewerten. Und die unsinnigen Regionen, in denen sich nichts abspielt, die kann ich auslassen. Das ist so ein Ansatz. Der andere Ansatz kommt eher aus der sensorbasierten Dinge, wie wir Menschen funktionieren. Wir haben viele Sensorsignale, die wir versuchen zu kanalisieren über unser neuronales Netz, das Hirn, und da über Lernmethoden sozusagen zu klassifizieren, was sind Muster, die wichtig sind. Dann habe ich ein implizites Modell, sage ich. Das habe ich aus der Erfahrung gelernt, hat ein Problem mit dem Roboter, weil der Mensch ist so ausgerichtet, dass wir als Säugling viel explorieren können, ohne dass uns was passiert. Also man muss ein bisschen Eingriff nehmen als Elternteil, aber im Wesentlichen macht das System 24 Stunden nichts anderes, als zu lernen und mit der Umwelt zu agieren, und es passiert nichts. Beim Roboter haben wir solche Systeme noch nicht so richtig, dass wir die selbstständig und ohne Aufsicht, sozusagen, explorieren lassen können. Kein Forscher will sich vier bis sechs Jahre neben den Roboter setzen und den beaufsichtigen, ohne klar zu sein, was für ein Ziel dabei rauskommt. Aber das ist so der andere Ansatz, der vielleicht langfristig verspricht, am flexibelsten zu sein. Aber für uns im Moment, für die Aufgaben, die wir lösen wollen, noch nicht der gangbare Weg ist. Was man auf jeden Fall hat, und das ist der Grundproblem und das Spannende an der Robotik, ist, wir haben eine abstrakte Sicht auf das Problem, sozusagen eine Planungssicht. Und dann kommt die Ausführung, dann kommt das echte Gerät und dann haben wir Unsicherheiten. Das heißt, wir wissen nicht genau, wo der Roboter sich bewegt. Der ist zwar genau kalibriert und wir können angeben, vielleicht auf einen halben Zentimeter, auf einen Millimeter, auf einen halben Millimeter genau. Je nach Aufgabenstellung reicht das nicht. Wenn ich irgendwas greifen will, was groß ist, dann reicht mir ein halber Zentimeter. Wenn ich Buchstaben schreiben will, dann brauche ich vielleicht einen Millimeter. Wenn ich eine Uhr reparieren will, dann brauche ich es im Sub-Millimeter-Bereich. Ich finde immer eine Anwendung, wo es dann nicht geht und wo es der Mensch noch kann. Da habe ich ein Problem. Da brauche ich entsprechende Sensorsignale, die ich verarbeite. Von meinem Plan muss ich abweichen. Das eine ist der Plan, und in der Wirklichkeit sieht es anders aus. Da ist ein Grundproblem drin. Da muss ich damit umgehen können. Eine Lösung ist, wie man es in der Robotik macht, das Feedback-Control. Aber das gilt nur für den Roboter. Warum mache ich Regelungen? Ich habe Sensoren, die messen. Da habe ich auch ein Modell, wo ich hinfahre. Da könnte ich auch einfach gesteuert hinfahren. Aber man weiß, das ist nicht präzise genug. Deswegen gibt es Rückkopplungen über Sensoren, über Kraft, über Positionssensorik usw. Damit werde ich genauer mit dem Roboter. Das gilt aber nur für den Roboter. Das Problem ist, die Umwelt kann ich nicht so augmentieren, dass sie sich sozusagen so optimal verhält. Ein Positionssensor an jedes Ding, das ich da manipulieren will, das funktioniert nicht. Das heißt, hier brauche ich jetzt Sensoren, die das liefern, aber die sind nicht mehr so sicher. Da ist der große Krux. Wenn ich einen Roboter baue, dann soll ich der Positionssensor, der liefert immer ein gültiges Signal. Das kommt nicht vor, dass da nichts passiert. Dann geht das Gelenk kaputt, dann ist es vorbei. Aber wenn ich Bildverarbeitung mache und wir was beobachte und mit der Hand reinfahre, dann sehe ich das Objekt dahinter nicht mehr. Das heißt, dann ist für den Feedback-Control das Signal kaputt und dann würde der Roboter stehen bleiben. Und da habe ich sozusagen eine Schicht dazwischen. Über eine Modellschätzung kann ich weiter laufen lassen. Ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, wenn das Objekt da gestanden ist und sich nicht bewegt hat und ich fahre mit der Hand rein, dann ist es normalerweise so, dass es stehen bleibt. Ich gehe davon aus, dass das Objekt immer noch da ist, wenn ich mich mit dem Roboter bewege. Wenn ich es anfasse, also wenn ich eine Berührung habe, dann kann ich es nicht mehr so genau sagen. Das heißt, ich habe so eine State Estimation von meiner Umwelt mit dabei, die ich teilweise auf Physik-Simulationen oder auf anderen Simulatoren beruhen lassen kann. Das generiert mir ein künstliches Signal, damit ich dann noch was weiß. Das heißt, ich muss eigentlich eine Vorausschätzung machen können, was ist die Wirkung meiner Aktion in der Umwelt, damit ich bewerten kann, was passiert. Das ist so der erste Schritt aus unserer Sicht in Richtung Intelligenz, damit ich weiß, was ich tue. Das ist noch keine höhere Intelligenz und so eine Aufgabe komme ich auch nicht, aber wo man sagt, ok, ich habe ein statistisches Modell, eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Situation nach meiner Roboteraktion so, so oder so ist. Und dann muss ich versuchen, sozusagen zu optimieren die Wahrscheinlichkeiten, dass am Ende der Zustand rauskommt, der gewünscht ist. Das ist dann eine Programmierung oder eine Herangehensweise, die mehr objekt- oder problemorientiert ist und nicht mehr so auf einer reinen Programmierung von der Roboterbahn beruht. Weil wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, eine Industrieroboter, da programmiere ich Bahnen. Also wenn ich mir ein Programm anschaue, dann fährt der Roboter von A nach B und macht auf und zu. Und wenn ich keine Kommentare habe in dem Programm, dann kann ich überhaupt nicht sagen, was der Roboter da gerade macht. Ich hatte mal so eine lustige Demonstration in einem Projekt, wo mein Partner Finger getreckt hat. Also die Hand-Kinematik. Wir haben so kleine Dinge gemacht und haben die Hände aufgenommen. Dann haben sie gesagt, okay, optisch mit einer Kamera. Und da hat man Menschen die Aufgabe gegeben, bestimmte Manipulationsaufgaben, Karten mischen oder irgendwelche Objekte drehen oder spitzen oder irgendetwas zu machen.
Zauberwürfel?
Ja gut, der Zauberwürfel natürlich auch. Die wesentliche Information war dann, die haben dann gesagt, was kriegen wir aus den Signalen raus? Wir haben jetzt genau die Fingerbewegungen auf Millimeter usw. Und dann haben wir gesagt, da leiten wir jetzt daraus ab, was der Mensch da macht und das übertragen wir dann irgendwie. Und dann ist die Frage, wie schwer ist das? Und die haben dann einfach dieses Objekt, was man da manipuliert hat, wenn man die Trajektorien aufgenommen hat und eine künstliche Hand, also eine virtuelle, ein 3D-Modell, dann animiert. Und das Modell, also das, was da manipuliert wird, wenn das weg ist, wenn man es nicht mehr sieht, also der Spitze ist weg. Und dann sieht man nur noch, wie die Finger sich bewegen in der Luft. Und das Objekt ist nicht mehr da. Und dann ist die Frage, kann der Mensch dann entscheiden, was der Gegenüber da gerade macht? Man hat keine Chance. Sobald das Objekt weg ist, man nur noch die Bewegung hat.
So ein bisschen wie bei Was Bin Ich mit dieser typischen Handbewegung.
Kann man nichts mehr sagen. Aber das bedeutet auch, dass wenn das Roboterprogramm sich nur damit befasst, wie die Bewegung ist für ein spezifisches Objekt, dann ist die eigentliche Aufgabenlösung ein Seiteneffekt. In der Informatik würde man sagen, es ist der Bug, der da rauskommt. Und das ist sozusagen das Ziel. Deswegen ist vielleicht Roboterprogrammierung auf der Basis der Trajektorien so schwierig.
Das heißt, der goldene Schlüssel zur Steuerung von Robotern ist in dem Sinne auch noch gar nicht gefunden. Man muss immer wieder abwägen, je nachdem, was die Aufgabe ist. Ob man jetzt mehr auf Fernsteuerung oder Fernprogrammierung geht, ob man da mit vordefinierten Erkennungsmustern arbeitet oder versucht, etwas Intelligenz zu formulieren, die dann die Lücke schließt.
Im Moment würden wir sagen, ja. Die Hoffnung ist natürlich, dass es irgendwann mal zu einer gemeinsamen Sicht konvergiert, sodass man dann weiß, wie man es macht, dass man sozusagen das Handbuch hat, dann wird es leichter. Aber im Moment ist es sehr schwierig. Ich würde sagen, man kann nicht sagen, welche Gruppe da die Nase vorne hat oder welche gewinnt. Das ist immer relativ spezifisch auf die Aufgaben. Das liegt natürlich auch daran, dass die Roboter immer noch sehr verschieden sind. Wir haben jetzt ein System wie Justin, es gibt noch ein paar andere Humanoide, die ähnlich gebaut sind mit Rädern, nicht mit Beinen noch, mit Armen und mehrfingrigen Händen. Die kann man vielleicht vergleichen, aber wenn ich einen ganz anderen Arm mit einer ganz anderen Ausrichtung habe und dann zwei Backengreifer und viel hänge auch von der Sensorik ab, habe ich Sensorfeedback. Wenn ich keins habe, dann ist sowieso ziemlich schwierig. Da ist es schwierig zu sagen, oder auch die Vergleichbarkeit zu haben. Es wird zwar immer mehr verlangt, dass man benchmarkt das, aber wenn man sich dann anschaut, wie so eine Aufgabe gelöst wird, da gibt es einen RoboCup at Home, da sind spezielle Plattformen, die alle die gleiche Aufgabe lösen, auf ganz verschiedene Art und Weise. Also da ist die Spielwiese schon noch groß.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz zum Justin, was mich jetzt interessieren würde, was kann jetzt diese Plattform? Wir haben darüber gesprochen, wie er aufgebaut ist, hat Finger, bewegt sich relativ schnell. Aber was kann jetzt die konkrete Ausgestaltung, also die Modelle, die jetzt hier stehen, was können die tatsächlich? Und natürlich dann damit verbunden, was ist die Vision, was sich für eine reale Anwendung aus diesen Fähigkeiten herausbilden kann, kann, wird, sollte, könnte.
Gut, also was kann die Plattform? Die Plattform hat die arme Hände. Das ist was, was agieren kann. Wir haben Kameras drauf. Wir haben auch inzwischen 3D-Sensorik. Also immer Stereokameras. Wir brauchen immerhin die Tiefe. Wir brauchen eine Objektlokalisierung. Und wir brauchen eigentlich auch so eine 3D-Geometrierekonstruktion. Objekte, die nicht vorher bekannt sind, die ich in eine Szene hineinmatschen kann, dass ich die auch erkennen kann. Die Plattform kann fahren und sie kann sich relativ zu bekannten Objekten lokalisieren. Wir haben also den Roboter, der hat einen Tisch, der hat einen Regal, das er sozusagen kennt, aus dem er sich bedienen kann und Dinge holen kann. Er kann zwischen den zwei hin und her fahren, sich die Objekte, die er für eine Manipulationsaufgabe braucht, suchen. Wobei die Manipulationsaufgabe vorher bekannt ist. Also der weiß, dass er zum Beispiel eine Kaffeemaschine braucht, Wasser braucht, ein Glas braucht. Wir haben so eine Espresso-Maschine bestückt mit so einer Kapsel und wie der Spender aussieht und solche Sachen. Die sind hinterlegt inzwischen in einer logischen Planungsdomäne. Das heißt, der Roboter kriegt eine Aufgabe und löst dann den Plan, was er alles braucht und wo er das herholt und wo er danach sucht und sowas selber auf. Das war so ein Beispiel für uns, das man abgeschlossen zeigen kann und das relativ viele Handlungen braucht. Also ich muss eben Gegenstände holen, die tue ich auf ein Tablett. Die werden also irgendwo zwischengespeichert. Dann nehme ich das ganze Tablett und fahre das an den Tisch und fange dann dort mit der Prozedur an. Dann habe ich eine Bedienung von einer Maschine, die kinematische Constraints hat. Das heißt, ich habe da Hebel, die ich umlegen muss und solche Dinge. Das ist auch wichtig, weil das ist mehr als nur ein Objekt anheben und das ist dann völlig frei. Was könnte das sein? Wenn ich eine Tür aufmachen muss, habe ich das gleiche Problem. Ich greife den Türgriff und dann muss ich mich an das Türscharnier halten. Das ist ein echtes Problem für einen Roboter, der nicht nachgiebig ist.
Der reißt dann einfach die ganze Tür raus?
Oder der Arm reißt ab. Wenn die Genauigkeiten nicht stimmen und sobald ich fahre, sind die Ungenauigkeiten im Bereich von Zentimetern. Bei einem Industrieroboter, wenn ich einen Zentimeter daneben läge, das würde schon ordentliche Prozesskräfte ausmachen. Der würde stehen bleiben. Da zeigt man so ein bisschen, was man kann, und dann versucht man natürlich auch die Bahn anzupassen. Das eine ist einfach mal weich zu sein. Dann haben wir die Kaffeemaschine gesucht.
Also weich sein in dem Sinne, dass die ganze Mechanik an sich schon mal ein bisschen nachgibt.
Ja, nachgiebig. Wobei wir kontrolliert nachgiebig sind. Wir stellen die Steifigkeit von dem System, können wir einstellen und variieren. Das andere Problem, da ist jetzt ein bisschen Raumgreifendes dabei. Wir haben jetzt nicht gesagt, wir fahren von einem Raum in den anderen mit dem Tablett und so, das ist weiter. Dann müssten wir im Haus navigieren können oder in unserem Institut. Das ist nicht unsere Hauptzielrichtung mit dem System. Dann habe ich diese ganzen Objekte lokalisiert und habe sie gegriffen. Dann sind so Mechanismen drin, dass ich sage, ich habe mit allen Sensoren, versuche ich immer, in so Referenzkontakte zu gehen. Das heißt, wenn ich das Tablett abstelle, dann stelle ich es bewusst auf den Tisch ab, bis ich eine Gegenkraft spüre. Ich lasse es nicht aus zwei Zentimeter fallen, weil ich gerade nicht so genau die Tischhöhe habe, sondern das ist sozusagen immer auf einem Sensor-Feedback basiert. Wobei das in dem Fall immer noch ein statischer Punkt ist, ein Threshold oder irgendeine Umgebung, nicht ein längerfristiger Zeitraum. Das haben wir in Einzelversuchen, aber im Gesamtsystem nicht integriert. Dann hat man diese Kaffeemaschine. Wenn man dieses Pad einfüllen will, hat man so eine Schublade aufzuziehen. Da hat man jetzt Genauigkeitsanforderungen an der Stelle. Die gehen über das hinaus, was sich über die Bildverarbeitung, die relativ einfach gehalten ist, erreichen kann. Das heißt, ich sehe das Objekt plus, minus zwei Zentimeter. Jetzt habe ich eine Schublade, die hat ungefähr Freiheit zwei Millimeter. Auf die muss ich es reinbringen. Wenn ich die Schublade erwische irgendwie und in den Knopf drücke und sie rausziehe, und da eine Federspanne, das kann ich ja machen, wie bei der Türe, ich mache mich nachgiebig, habe ich eine Federspannung. Sobald dieser kinematische Constraint weg ist, dass ich in der Schubladenführung bin, schnallt mir die Schublade, um das, was Fehler ist, zur Seite. Dann fülle ich jetzt das Pad ein, weil das ist eine Relativbewegung von einer Hand zur anderen. Die habe ich ziemlich genau, weil den Roboter kenne ich gut, aber die Umwelt weiß ich nicht so. Und jetzt will ich wieder in die Maschine rein. Und was mache ich jetzt? Jetzt bin ich irgendwo daneben. Ich weiß es nicht, da kann ich es nochmal lokalisieren. Gibt es in der anderen Richtung zwei Zentimeter falsch. Das heißt, da sind jetzt Mechanismen drin, dass ich sage, wenn das ist, dann mache ich, ich fahre an die Schublade hin, spanne sozusagen mit dem Zusammendrücken der Finger die Feder und mache dann einen Ausgleich. Ich lasse jetzt die Feder los, die sich virtuell gespannt hat. Ich bringe den Arm sozusagen in Ruhe und dann ziehe ich raus. Dann schnallt er mir nicht mehr zur Seite. Dann habe ich sozusagen mit dem Zugreifen und dem Kontakt zur Maschine eine lokale Referenz geschlossen und bin jetzt in einer Wiederholgenauigkeit von dem Millimeterbereich, in dem ich brauche. Was wir jetzt versuchen auf dem System, also das Ding kalibriert sich quasi selbst, an der Kaffeemaschine. Das ist auch ähnlich, wie wir es als Mensch machen, wenn wir eine Lupe haben, zum Beispiel, um irgendwas Feines zu machen, dann geht es über die Optik. Aber wir versuchen dann Stück links, Stück rechts, wir empfangen nicht absolut, wir machen immer relativ. Und wir versuchen, das ganze System so aufzubauen, dass wir eine Kette von diesen Relativgenauigkeiten haben, sodass wir immer genauer werden. Das kann man nämlich zum Beispiel auch so machen, wenn ich von einer Hand, wo ich was draufsetzen will, mit einem Teil und das andere Teil muss ziemlich genau sein, dann kann ich mit dem Finger dieses andere Teil berühren, und dann habe ich von meinem Griff in der Hand und der Referenz zu dem Finger habe ich eine lokale Referenz in der Hand geschlossen. Da komme ich auf ziemlich hohe Genauigkeiten. Im Moment sind viele von diesen Dingen noch handcodiert, es sind spezielle Modelle dabei, aber das ist sozusagen die Herangehensweise, wie wir versuchen, das zu automatisieren, um dann angeben zu können, ich habe eine Aufgabe, die hat bestimmte Genauigkeitsanforderungen, und dann sagt mir mein Programmevaluierungsmodul, ich brauche hier noch Zwischenreferenzen. Das geht nicht. Von dem Roboter und der Lokalisierung sind die Genauigkeiten nicht genug. Das sind alles statistische Werte, das kann auch mal zufällig stimmen, aber im Wesentlichen kann man sich darauf nicht verlassen, wenn man jetzt wirklich in Fertigungsumgebungen gehen will. Das sind so die Fertigkeiten, die der Justin kann, also dieses Kaffeemachen. Dann haben wir natürlich das Problem, was wir jetzt auch angehen. Wir haben eine Kaffeemaschine, ein Tablett, eine Tasse usw. Die haben alle funktionale Eigenschaften. Die sind ähnlich für verschiedene Kaffeemaschinen und verschiedene Tablets usw. Aber sobald wir eine neue Geometrie nehmen, müssen wir das Programm neu schreiben. Das heißt, wir verlieren sozusagen die Informationen über, wie man das mit dem Tablett macht, wenn die Geometrie sich leicht ändert. Da gibt es ein Projekt, wo wir sagen, wir wollen für funktionale Objektklassen, also eine Tasse, die hat immer einen Henkel und manchmal verschiedene Formen, aber die Funktion ist gleich. Wenn ich was trinken will, dann nehme ich es am Henkel. Wenn ich stapeln will, dann nehme ich es von oben und stecke es in diesen Stapel rein usw. Da gibt es Funktionsklassen. Da untersuchen wir, wie kann man, wie kann man, wenn man eine Korrespondenz findet in der Wahrnehmung zwischen den zwei Modellen, also wie bilden wir eine Geometrie in die andere ab, sozusagen den Rumpf der Tasse und den Rand der Tasse und den Henkel der Tasse, da finden wir Korrespondenzen. Das ist ein Bildverarbeitungsproblem. Und wenn wir das haben, dann können wir daraus ableiten, wo die Griffe jetzt liegen, implizit. Das heißt, wir haben ein Beispielprogramm, wo wir eine Manipulation mit einer Tasse zeigen. Mit bestimmten Griffen, an der bestimmten Geometrie. Und wenn wir jetzt eine neue Tasse sehen, dann muss es eine Klassifikation geben und sagen, okay, das ist was, das sieht aus wie eine Tasse. Und dann machen wir diese Korrespondenzen. Und dann können wir die Greifpunkte, wir sagen Warpen, also übertragen auf die neue Tasse und versuchen, die Manipulation anzupassen. Das heißt, ich stell den Roboter vor ein neues Objekt, eine neue Objektgeometrie, die hat er noch nie gesehen, aber er erkennt, dass sie von einer ähnlichen funktionalen Klasse ist. Und damit versucht er, das, was er weiß von der alten, zu übertragen auf die neue. Damit hat er noch nicht wirklich was Intelligentes gemacht, aber er hat versucht, diese Funktionalität zu übertragen, implizit an einem Beispiel. Gibt dann auch so Beispiele, wenn man sagt, ich habe den Tisch gedeckt und ich sehe, dass ich die geometrische Verortung, wo die Sachen sind, Teller ist links Gabel, rechts Messer. Und jetzt sagt jemand, deckt den Tisch, legt es irgendwie hin, dann würde der versuchen, das in einer ähnlichen Konstellation wieder hinzulegen, weil er es schon mal gesehen hat. Das wäre sozusagen der nächste Schritt, wo wir sagen, ist Interpolation noch, also ist was Gesehenes oder was von Hand programmiertes nachgemacht, aber adaptiert. Es würde eine riesige Flexibilitätserweiterung gewesen sein, nicht wirklich intelligent, aber geht ein Stück in die richtige Richtung. Ist aber nicht so einfach. Kann man jetzt auch sehen und sagen, okay, jetzt gibt es auch noch Bewegungen. Wir haben jetzt angefangen mit Löffeln, wenn ich eine Tasse umrühre und der Bereich ändert sich oder beim Aufschrauben. Das Problem ist, um sowas zu lernen, braucht man immer viele Beispiele. Am Roboter das hundertmal auszuführen oder in verschiedene Art und Weise zu programmieren, ist sehr aufwendig und die Simulatoren liefern nicht so günstige Ergebnisse. Aber den ersten Schritt hat man getan, da muss man noch viel machen, aber im Wesentlichen kann man zeigen, dass das funktioniert. Also die Übertragung auf verschiedene Funktionsklassen von Objekten kann funktionieren. Wir haben dann angefangen, so eine Datenbank zu machen, so wie in der Informatik, objektorientiert. Ich sag, jetzt klassifiziere ich mal Objekte, da macht es ja auch Sinn. Ein Objekt ist, was man nehmen kann, also was am Tisch lose ist, was keine Constraints hat. Dann habe ich so umschließende Griffe und sowas, die weiß ich, wie ich für die Objekte mache. Und sobald ich ein Objekt in irgendeine von diesen Klassen klassifizieren kann, kann ich dann auch die Aufgabe ausführen. Wenn ich sage, ich habe ein schweres Objekt wie ein Stein, und ein Hammer ist auch ein schweres Objekt, und ich kann mit dem Hammer, mit dem schweren Teil, auf den Nagel hauen, dann käme der Roboter auch darauf, dass er mit dem Stein auch auf den Hammer hauen kann.
Das heißt eigentlich bräuchte man so eine Art, eigentlich muss man so eine Art Abstraktion der Realität auch mit einführen, so eine Datenbank der Dinge, die so in mehrdimensionaler Art und Weise versucht, alles nach Form, Funktion und Eigenschaft zu gruppieren.
Das braucht man auf jeden Fall, mal zwei Möglichkeiten dahin zu kommen. Entweder man gibt es vor in Kategorien, die man kennt, weil wenn man lernt, macht man auch nichts anderes. Man lernt ja nicht auf der untersten Ebene der Sensorsignale, sondern man versucht, dem Lernen auch Abstraktionen zu bilden. Dann habe ich ein gelerntes Label, das für mich nichts bedeutet, es hat irgendeine Nummer oder was auch immer, hat die Bedeutung nicht. Das System sucht sich irgendwann selber. Oder ich bringe das eben von außen rein. Wir haben jetzt versucht, für die Beispielprogramme, die wir da aufgenommen haben, haben wir auch keine Labels. Da hat ein Mensch gesessen und hat das dann gelabelt. Aber was der Code-Analyzer oder das Modul, das lernt, rausgefunden hat und gesagt, dieser Teil ist ein bestimmter Aspekt. Und dann kann ich mir den Teil anschauen und gebe dem einen Namen, damit ich ihn nachher wiederfinde. Aber im Wesentlichen hat er dann nur eine Nummer, das ist implizit. Das wäre eigentlich, was man sich wünscht, aber dann wird das System zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ein bisschen unnachvollziehbar. Die Bugging ist dann ein bisschen schwierig.
Ich habe einen Vorschlag für die Weihnachtsfeier. Ich glaube, das Team sollte in ein Dunkelrestaurant geführt werden. Das scheint mir so eine passende Umgebung zu sein für Leute, die im Wesentlichen lernen müssen, andere im Dunkeln tappen zu lassen. Was für Anwendungen sind da jetzt gedacht? Telepräsenz ist ja schon so gefallen. Das klingt ein bisschen abstrakt. Jenseits der typischen Roboter-Industrie-Anwendungen sind die hinter der Forschung stehende Visionen.
Also der Bereich Telepräsenz ist in zweierlei Hinsicht interessant. Einmal haben wir auch ein System, das versucht, minimalinvasive Chirurgie zu machen. Da kann man die Fernsteuerung sozusagen aus der Nähe machen. Da nimmt man dem Chirurgen Arbeit ab, indem man die Roboter-Bewegung, die einzelnen Gelenke übernimmt. Und der Chirurg steuert im Prinzip nur das Werkzeug.
Also jetzt nicht mit 100 Kilometern Abstand dazwischen.
Der sitzt im OP direkt neben dem Tisch, hat das Bild aus dem Stereolaparaskop, also das ist eine 3D-Ansicht, sieht die Werkzeuge da drin, sieht den Patienten, also den Bauchraum, was er operiert und bekommt ein Kraftfeedback.
Wozu braucht man dann auch diese Telepräsenz, wenn man doch eigentlich sowieso nah dran ist?
Das Problem ist, wenn man nah dran ist und an den Instrumenten arbeitet, dann hat man eine relativ schwierige, nachzuvollziehende Kinematik, weil sie im Bauchraum ein Loch haben und sie können in diesem Loch hin- und herfahren und sie können aber Drehungen und Orientierungsänderungen nur machen, indem sie sich um dieses Loch herum bewegen. Das kann man ganz einfach ausprobieren, indem man einen Bleistift nimmt und versucht zu schreiben, indem man oben oberhalb, wenn man so einen Krigel macht und den da durchsteckt mit dem Zeigefinger und dem Daumen, und oberhalb am Ende des Schreibtisches Bleistifts versucht man, was zu schreiben. Und unten bewegt sich der Bleistift hin und her. Das ist nicht ganz so intuitiv.
Das Halten der Position ist sozusagen die Herausforderung.
Ja, auch wenn ich jetzt ein Stück weiter nach links oder rechts kathesisch fahre, und das kann Mathematik relativ leicht ausrechnen. Wenn ich teleoperiere, gebe ich über ein Eingabegerät die kathesische Bewegung links, rechts, oben, unten und Drehungen vor. Und der Rechner rechnet aus, wohin der Roboter bewegen muss, damit genau die Bewegung im Bauchraum passiert.
Also eine aktive Stützung der eigentlichen mechanischen Tätigkeiten, die man als Operateur ausführen muss. Das ist so quasi das Ziel.
Damit kann ich mich wieder eins zu eins bewegen, wie ich es mir vorstelle, und muss mich nicht darum kümmern, wie die speziellen Bewegungskommandos am Roboter dazu sind. Und ich kann eben, gut, das Feedback mit der Kraft hätte ich auch, wenn ich direkt mit dem Instrument operiere. Ich muss aber nicht halten, und ich habe auch in dem Fall, dass ich sozusagen müde werde oder sonst irgendwas, habe ich nicht das Problem. Ich kann ja nicht einfach die Instrumente fallen lassen. Ich kann aber einfach die Steuerung wegnehmen, und der Roboter hält dann einfach. Das ist eine Erleichterung. Wird auch viel gemacht schon. Da gibt es schon Systeme, die haben allerdings keine Kraftdruckkopplung. Da hat man eine direkte Anwendung. Und es gibt auch Fälle, wo man sagt, wie man möchte eigentlich.
Und man hält ja auch so ein bisschen die Menschen von dem offenen Bauchraum fern.
Gut, bei minimalinversiv hat man meistens überhaupt nur das Punktiert. Also da ist nichts mit offen. Irgendwer muss es auch aufmachen. Da bin ich jetzt nicht der Experte, ob das wirklich so viel bringt. Aber die Wunden sind dann eher da klein. Ansonsten ist ein aktuelles Thema, so ein Stichwort ist Wartung von Industrieanlagen. Das wirkt erstmal komisch. Aber es gibt Anwendungsfälle, zum Beispiel auf Ölplattformen. Wenn die offshore sind, weit weg, habe ich ein Problem, wenn ich da Personal vor Ort habe, dann brauche ich immer ein Krankenhaus und einen Arzt und alle möglichen Infrastruktur, weil ich in Schlechtwetterfällen oder auch in Gutwetterfällen nicht rechtzeitig da bin. Sozusagen das zu betreiben. Da ist viel automatisiert, aber nicht alles. Und dann muss ich auch bei schlechtem Wetter irgendwie Leute rausbringen und so weiter. Da gibt es Überlegungen, ob man das alles fernsteuerbar machen kann. Da sind wir auch in Kontakt mit Firmen, die so Ölplattformen betreiben. Ist aber eine sehr schwierige Umgebung. Ist wieder ähnlich wie Weltraum, aber jetzt haben wir Salzwasser und Kälte und Wind und alle möglichen anderen Effekte.
Auch nichts, was die Elektronik jetzt besonders mag.
Was auch ein interessantes Feld ist, sind dann genau ähnlich Windkraftwerke. Da hat man auch ein Problem, wenn man Wartungspersonal hinbringt, dass man sicherstellen muss, dass man sie wiederholt. Sonst sagt die Berufsgenossenschaft zu Recht, das ist uns zu heikel, wenn da was passiert. Er ist die Frage, was man mit aktuellen Systemen da machen kann. Aber da gibt es bestimmt Potenzial, wobei man jetzt neu darüber nachdenkt. Da muss man sich immer überlegen, wieviel kann ich in der Anlage automatisieren und wieviel brauche ich jetzt wirklich noch extern von dem Roboter. Oft geht es auch um Inspektion. Einfach um zu sagen, hier habe ich einen Fehler, jetzt brauche ich eine Beurteilung der Lage. Was ist da? Läuft da irgendwo was aus? Das sehe ich ja dann nicht. Ich sehe Druckabfall in dem Segment. Was bedeutet das? Da muss ich jemand hinschicken. Und man hat das auch in Kernkraftwerken. Da gab es auch die Diskussion, ob der Unfall in Fukushima ist natürlich extrem, weil da viele Faktoren zusätzlich dazukamen. Aber in Deutschland gibt es ja auch die vorgehaltenen Robotersysteme. Also man kommt da drauf und sagt, man braucht diese Systeme schon in den Reaktoren drin, falls ein Störfall ist, sodass ich dann von außen drauf kann. Und da ist natürlich auch Teleoperation und Telepräsenz mal erst das Naheliegendste. Weil da ist eine Situation, die ist neu. Die ist so neu, dass auch die Experten nicht wissen, was da passiert und erst mal einen Lageüberblick bekommen. Also davon zu erwarten, dass der Roboter da was autonom macht, ist eher unwahrscheinlich. Das sind so die direkten Anwendungen in der Telepräsenz. Ins Richtung autonome Systeme geht, hat man natürlich viel, was in der Produktion passieren soll. Klassisch würde ich das dann nicht mehr nennen. Man überlegt da sehr viel, wieder in Richtung Werkstattfertigung zu machen. Also wenn es kleinere Serien sind, so Inseln, auf denen man arbeitet, und wo der Werker anfängt und sagt, die Produktvielfalt oder der Wechsel zwischen den Modellen ist so schnell, dass man davon ausgeht, dass der Werker die ersten Serien immer selber machen muss. Und dass man gar nicht so eine lange Planung für die Automatisierung hat, sondern dass der Werker vor Ort dann sagt, ok, hier gibt es jetzt Routine-Tätigkeiten, ich teile mir meine Arbeit ein, wie muss ich wann was machen, und der kann sich dann Roboter holen und Teile von diesem Fertigungsprozess auslagern, direkt vor Ort. Dann muss er ihn auch programmieren können, dann muss das entsprechend einfach gehen. Das ist eine Anwendung, die andere Anwendung ist so, wenn ich diese Inseln habe, dann müssen die immer mit Teilen versorgt werden. Das heißt, da fährt dann ein Stapler und fährt Sachen hin und her, aber ein Stapler ist groß in viele Teile. Wenn ich keine so großen Serien habe, brauche ich weniger Teile, dann muss ich das konfektionieren und bringen. Das ist so eine Anwendung für die Roboter. Und dann hat man natürlich so den breiten Einsatz, auch im Kopf, den Haushalt sehen wir als schwierig an, weil was Sinnvolles im Haushalt machen ist dann bügeln. Da sehen wir den Justin jetzt noch ein Stück entfernt.
Oder aufräumen.
Familie mit kleinen Kindern würden in die Hände klatschen vor Freude.
Ja, die Frage ist, was im langfristigen Versuch dann rauskommt. Wir haben dann eine Generation von Kindern, die nicht gewohnt ist aufzuräumen. Was das für Auswirkungen hat, weiß ich nicht. Ja, das stimmt. War ja auch nur so ein Traum. Ist die Frage, natürlich. Ich kann das auch nachvollziehen. Das Kinderzimmer aufräumen ist ein ewiger Kampf. Aber das eine ist, dass das Zimmer dann aufgeräumt ist. Und die andere Frage ist, was lernt das System, das Kind, dabei, wenn das mal was aufräumen muss?
Ja, dass man gar nicht aufräumen muss, weil das macht ja da schon der Roboter.
Ja, genau. Wie wird das dann später sein? Ich bräuchte zum Beispiel ein System, das mein Schreibtisch aufräumt. Aber da hängt auch mehr dran.
Hilft auch nicht wirklich. Hatte denn das überhaupt so Zukunft? Der Roboter im Haushalt, diese japanische Traumwelt, findet das überhaupt Akzeptanz? Das ist ja auch so ein kulturelles Ding. Ich glaube, in Japan wird der Roboter primär immer so als mein elektronischer Freund, der mir irgendwie bei allem helfen kann, gesehen. Bei uns ist ja Robotik eigentlich immer sehr, also auf der einen Seite sehr, dieses industriell-maschinelle, automatisierende, auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite aber auch immer so ein bisschen diese düstere, schwebende, schwebende, so eine Vision von der Maschine, die die Welt unter Kontrolle bringt. Wir haben das in Filmen, etc. überall. Da ist wenig vom Freund wirklich die Rede. Kann sich das überhaupt hier manifestieren?
Ich würde das nie als Freund bezeichnen. Also, das ist, wenn der Roboter mein Freund ist. Wir hätten jetzt mal keine Angst davor. Es gibt natürlich Maschinen, die sind leistungsfähig, aber an der Intelligenz fehlt es weit. Deswegen sehe ich die Gefahr, dass die Übernahme bevorsteht. Sonst sehe ich das überhaupt nicht. Da gibt es einen Ausschalter und die Batterie ist leer. Dann ist es vorbei. An Intelligenz schlägt er uns noch lange nicht. Im Haushalt ist die Vorstellung, wir haben eine Vorstellung von einem Roboter, der muss eine sinnvolle Aufgabe erfüllen. Er muss mir irgendwas abnehmen. Wenn wir an diesen Helfer denken, davon gehen wir aus. Wenn er die erfüllen muss aus dem Stand, dann wird es sehr schwer werden. Da ist an Leistungsfähigkeit im Moment wenig gegeben. Dann hat man pauschal den Haushalt im Kopf. Dann reden alle möglichen Leute von verschiedenen Dingen. Man muss das mit einfachen Dingen sehen. Man sieht überall Einzug von Technik im Haushalt. Da hat man gar keine Angst. Da ist überall eine Regelung, eine Intelligenz, die einen an manchen Stellen schmerzt. Der Fernseher ist auch intelligent geworden. Manchmal macht er Dinge, die ich gar nicht will. Und dann stürzt er auch noch ab. Das hat er früher nicht getan. Das Telefon stürzt ab, hat es früher auch nicht getan. Das akzeptiert man alles. Solange der Roboter keinen Fehler machen darf in einer Umgebung, wo der Mensch auch Fehler macht. Also wenn ich jemanden zum Beispiel sage, ich habe jemanden, der bei mir putzt oder mir aufräumt, dann muss ich damit leben, dass Dinge kaputt gehen. Das ärgert mich dann, aber das ist akzeptabel, weil das ist menschlich. Wenn der Roboter das macht, ist es nicht akzeptabel. Der Roboter soll 100% funktionieren, so wie ein Auto. Das ist auch mal eine Panne, aber das erwarte ich eigentlich, dass das immer geht. Das wird schwer realisierbar sein im Haushalt erstmal. Und dann sieht man allerdings andererseits auch, dass man an manchen Stellen das schon akzeptiert. Es gibt ja diese Staubsauger-Roboter und die ersten Generationen waren technische Gemix. Die haben nicht wirklich sauber gemacht. Da ist ein Ding rumgefahren und das hat auch irgendwie gesaugt. Das eine oder andere Staubkorn ist da auch gelandet, aber gesäubert hat es nicht. Und das haben trotzdem Leute gekauft, sodass sich da ein Markt etabliert hat. Und inzwischen saugen, also die haben tatsächlich inzwischen eine Reinigungsleistung. Am Anfang war es auch so, dass sie anfangs haben versucht, regelmäßige Muster zu fahren ohne große Intelligenz. Dann haben sie sich nicht verkauft, haben wir von Herstellern gehört, weil das war irgendwie langweilig. Also es hat ja nicht sauber gemacht und zwar langweilig. Und dann hat man ihnen so zufällige Bewegungsmuster gegeben. Wenn man also unendlich lang wartet, dann ist er auch überall drüber gekommen, ist alles sauber. Jetzt hat das Ding plötzlich ein Eigenleben entwickelt und war lustig. Es hat immer noch nicht sauber gemacht, aber es hat mehr Zufriedenheit bei den Käufern erzeugt.
Weil man könnte zumindest so zugucken, wie es sich so...
Genau, es bewegt sich so. Wir haben mal so eine Navigation für so einen kleinen Roboter, der so lustig sich immer hin und her bewegt und dreht, auf einen großen Roboter gebracht. Weil wir selber da nichts hatten, haben gesagt, wir kaufen das und wir setzen das auf den Roboter ein. Und es ist überhaupt nicht mehr lustig, wenn der Justin sich dauernd in der Gegend herumdreht. So wie dieser Kleine. Der macht nichts anderes. Der hat genau die gleiche Mimik, aber das ist überhaupt nicht lustig. Das schaut aus, wie ein Besoffener, der herumpfortelt. Plötzlich ist das nicht mehr lustig. Und jetzt sind die Staubsauger-Roboter besser geworden. Und jetzt fängt man an, der misst das Gebäude ein, wird auch intelligenter. Und fährt jetzt eine möglichst effiziente Bahn, sodass er schnell fertig ist. Weil er eine Reinigungsleistung hat. Und jetzt akzeptieren das die Leute auch. Also da muss man gucken. Und dann muss man schauen, dass man sagt, wie ist der Anfang? Der Anfang ist immer so ein Gadget. Dass ich sage, ich habe mal eine kritische Masse, mit der ich ausprobieren kann. Weil solange wir nur im Labor herumfahren und dann so eine kleine Ecke im Labor sauber machen, wird sich das nicht durchsetzen. Und das ist mit allen Dingen, man muss diesen Einstieg schaffen. Und diese Staubsauger, oder jetzt gibt es auch Rasenmäher-Roboter oder so, die werden schon auch Technologien weiterentwickeln, die für den Rest dann sinnvoll sind. Aber jetzt Handhabung im Haushalt ist halt schwierig. Weil was mache ich, wenn das mit dem Spülmaschine-Einräumen nicht klappt und ich brauche alle drei Monate ein neues Service?
Ich glaube, der Durchbruch kommt mit dem Wäsche-Sortieren.
Ich hätte immer gerne einen, der nach dem Kochen die Küche aufräumt. Aber das ist natürlich auch eine schwierige Sache.
Gut, ich sehe schon. An Wünschen für den Haushalt gibt es keinen Mangel. Und hier gibt es auch keinen Mangel an weiteren Herausforderungen für die Forschung, für die Robotik am Boden. Auch teilweise mit Blick auf die Raumfahrt. Ich denke, an der Stelle können wir jetzt hier auch mal den Sack zumachen. Vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zu Robotern und ihrer gefühlten Intelligenz. Ja, und auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war jetzt die 50. Ausgabe. Wir machen weiter. Tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.